[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a shocking end to the 12th game of the
World Chess Championship as world number
1 Magnus Carlsen offered a draw from a
better position and with more time on
the clock to take the match to a
tiebreaker
will the best rapid enlist player on the
planet prove his strategy correct or
will the Challenger pull off an upset
for the ages it's time to crown a
champion in a heart-stopping finale
exciting action live from London starts
right now
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our World
Championship coverage we are now in
rapid playoffs as Fabiano Kara wanna see
Lewis's own challenger for the world
title is playing against this man Magnus
Carlsen the reigning king and after 12
rounds tied six-six and we have a
playoffs in fact we're already getting
who's in on the first game of a
four-game rapid playoff I'm Jennifer
Shehadeh I'm here with Yasser Sara Juan
and yeah the first good news of the day
you were right about some things we've
got in English we've got an English and
Jen it's great to be with you I'm in
panic mode over here I've been nervous
difficulty sleeping and we have an
English with this early e to e for the
first few moves went slowly and we've
got well as soon as white plays d3 we've
got what we would call the BOD Vinik
pong triangle White has pawns on C 44
and d3 in the middle of the board the
whole setup we're in a tie-break four
games of rapid chess first to score two
and a half will win Jennifer let's take
a look at the format that's right we've
got game 25 buzz a 10-second increment
that's what we're at right now get to
two and a half points it's over you're
the world champion after the rapid we go
to blitz which is repeated up to five
times if needed and then we go to
Armageddon extremely unlikely probably
less than 1% so that said this match is
defying the odds all 12 games being
drawn the first time in history for that
Magnus does start with the white pieces
definitely an edge in this type of
format in my opinion agree considering
that we might you know depending on how
it goes match could be over a three game
that's lying and we've got Grandmaster
Maurice Ashley for a fast fact as we
watch this playoff develop indeed you
said it's an edge for Magnus to have the
white pieces in this format but Magnus
doesn't need an edge because he is
simply the best rapid player on the
planet bar none
it's just unquestioned it would be a big
upset if Fabi were able to defeat him
and not just because it's Magnus but
because no one has ever defeated
champion in this format in fact of the
three matches in the 12 game format that
have gone to tie break the champ has won
every single one on first it was a
chronic defeating T'Pol off then uh none
defeating Gelfand and Carlsen himself
smashing car yeah kyun in there tie
break in New York so the trend is
against Fabi all the way
what will he have well he's gonna have
to show heart grit and determination to
be able to pull off what would indeed be
an upset for the ages
Thank You Maurice and again 2016 World
Championship match similar situation
tied Magnus drew Game one
drew Game two but then came with
back-to-back victories in games three
and four and Maurice you and I were
talking about this yesterday and I think
you made a great explanation of why
games one and two are so crucial to
fabbi absolutely you really want to have
a lead early because the more games you
play the bet the more the stronger
player gets comfortable and the more the
weight factor kicks in he starts to say
look I'm the big dog here I'm the better
player so you need the short of the
match if let's say it was a one gamer
then Bobby would have his best chance
anything could happen in one game if you
made it 15 20 games a rapid match Magnus
is just gonna start getting really
comfortable and showing why he's the
number one player so Bobby I think needs
this game to go okay would black
maybe get a draw not saying he's playing
for it but if he does that he gets the
white pieces and he could hit Magnus
then taking the lead with only two games
left then he really has a chance put the
pressure on Magnus but I think if he
slips up in one of these two games boy
it's gonna be rough almost impossible
speaking of big dogs we have Garry
Kasparov joining us and a the beginning
of Game two so you're gonna want to keep
your eyes peeled to this broadcast guys
Garry Kasparov we can keep the position
up as well yes we've got it yeah we've
got this English position how do you
feel about this choice I gotta say
compared to a lot of other people
I don't think fabi's chances are a that
underdog yeah I I believe in favi and
you know realize that you would say that
well but you know who agrees with me
Garry Kasparov
he said he thinks the chances are way
closer to even than he originally
predicted and another person who agrees
with me this one might actually scared
Bobby fans okay
Hikaru Nakamura he even retreated in a
very interesting tweet he he
Nakara said oh please you've got it up
on the board there that he felt that in
the 12 games
fabbi had out prepared a Magnus that his
transitions in the middle game was
better and even his end game play he had
out foxed Magnus and that it would be
very strange if Abby were to lose this I
don't think I don't think the car was
said that he thought Fabi was favored no
no all he said was he thought it would
be fair fairer for Fabi to when given
how the twelve games went and I think
also with Gary and by the way this move
a six yeah well I want to get into that
quickly but Gary Gary also felt that it
would be that Magnus is losing a bit of
nerves to have taken a draw in game wow
that you feel like maybe Magnus is not
all there that said if you're gonna bet
money boy
Magnus is very hard to bet against
Magnus but that said also the Bob Vinick
English you know it brings back memories
of my my great friend now late friend
Ronald Simpson who taught me this system
which I played for years with white and
got a lot of victories all the way up to
almost 2400 level before who was handled
at the higher levels and I couldn't keep
playing it I had to switch to some main
lines but this line I just have so many
fond memories about great victories with
the white pieces this formation I've
never seen C 6 and a 6 and B 5
I seen B 5 get executed but with C 6 and
this pawn still on D 7 yes sir you're a
specialist in this have you ever seen
this kind of triangle formation with V
Phi being played this quickly no very
very peculiar I mean I've never seen the
burn variation of Kings Indian defense
does have a 6 and C 6 and B 5 involved
short in that but in this case is d6 is
on the wall over on g7 right right so
this is way way way off the beaten track
I'm thinking that
that Magnus will get no advantage should
he capture so that that's out Magnus
would get no advantage should he play
either b3 or d3 I think it comes down to
this challenge that Magnus literally has
to play d4 and if you got a position I'm
just putting it on the board like this I
think white has a respectable chance of
fighting for advantage because he's
picking up a tempo so do you know I mean
any of these lines to play for a 5 no
because you're attacking like I was
thinking about taking with a knight
instead of a queen taking with the
knight on d4 and so the Queen here in
this moment yeah and then like trying to
play 35 and 45 and Knight f5 sorry but
Queen takes looks so natural of course
he's played by the way he did on the
board nice I don't like taking as black
I feel like you're asking for it yes in
that kind of position it just seems to
me that and he did play d6 yeah I was
about to say seems to me these six is
required and the problem also the
problem now more than anything is that
Bishop sitting on b4 to me King well
that's one of the problems the other
problem that Queen side development that
Bishop Knight and rook getting quick
harmony that's why I fell you need to
play d6 as fast as possible get your
Bishop out I'm not even sure maybe your
knight has to precede it maybe you need
to play Knight d7 ambition to b7 right
and hold that position because
coordination on the Queen side is an
issue and also you played a6
so if white gets any speedy something
going and a6 will prove itself to be a
tempo loss so black is taking a big risk
in this position in this original setup
and I can guarantee you magaz are gonna
sit on this position and say where is my
edge where is my edge he's gonna look
for it now because this is not a
standard setup that you see in this
formation well your areas how do you
rate White's advantage here dude yes I
am very happy with white and I think
it's very important to pursue the
initiative with precision and the way I
see it this Bishop actually on b4 is
misplaced and what I want to do is get
as much development
as quickly as possible so I would like
to start with the move Queen b3 give me
that bishop I would love to encourage
you to play Bishop takes c3 Queen takes
c3 I've got the two bishops I've got b3
I've got Bishop a3 idea so you can't
give me the two bishops so you got to
either take the move and lose a tempo
with Bishop a5 or you've got to do
something else that you don't really
want to do which is play c5 or a5
Maurice your take after Queen b3 and you
play Bishop a5 okay okay and I will play
rook e1 this is we're getting that
initiative from develop and very quickly
Queens would have to go to e7 in that
setup though young black is in crouch
mode right this is like Crouching Tiger
he's in right now yeah and he has to be
very careful for the game to explode
because if it does he has a bishop on c8
knight on b8 that's gonna be a problem
white doesn't want to play casual moves
you see Magnus looking at it now he just
want to do something like there should
be three Queen c2 bringing the rooks
over even though he'll have a little bit
of a space advantage but his Center is
collapsing and that the pawn on e5 and
opponent b5 the +2 those things those
pawns that maneuver is that white Center
could fall apart and if white doesn't
maintain any integrity in the middle of
the board then black will just develop
around and get the c5 square for a piece
and be very comfortable so right now
this is why Magnus is thinking it's
Magnus you focused on this position
because he knows he gives the guy a
couple of freebie moves but I could be
back in the game he can't just be casual
so expect something more incisive and
that's that disposition is hyper critter
with a risky formation for a white for
black to have chosen is this critical
game right given the Fabi c 6a 6b 5
without d6 amazing that he's done this
yeah amazing only from the heart
standpoint if not higher I'm not
assessing this position because I feel
personally that I would have preferred
oh and look at what has happened a3
Bishop takes on c3
hold on the me has actually occurred in
the
he's conceded the two bishops and
captured upon on c4 right now what a big
decision so we have already on the board
in the move a3
okay I thought pursuing with precision
the development advantage with Queen b3
I didn't really consider sacking the
pawn
justice I mean we can take on e5 and
then and then go for a c4 right well if
we take on c5 and go Queen here the
bishop is gonna settle nicely on e6 and
I won't be able to play d4 default I
could play for f4 f5 in that case I mean
are you really gonna be able to hold on
to that pawn and see for a long term
don't know very noble this f4 idea to me
like I know you love this position as an
English player well the other position
especially right I'm looking at this and
I'm feeling excited about the fact that
I have this lever on tap with or without
exchanging of playing f4 which can a
stop your Bishop from coming to e6
gracefully and be kind of thinking about
taking and playing Bishop g5 in some
lines right so guys this position is all
about the dark squares that's that's
what it's about white now has a dark
square Bishop thank you so you can't
even argue my friend took on these five
and then you played 94 you can't even
argue about the two bishops because your
Bishop on g2 is not anybody to write
home about unless somehow it explodes
into the game after f4 and some
exchanges and even then it's not about
that piece what this position is about
is that Garcia Bishop on c1 that Bishop
combined with that knight on e4 they're
about to look at black and say we're
gonna beat you up on these squares going
to create a bind that you're never going
to be able to do anything about and it's
because of that fractured dark squares
set up on a 6 C 6 C 4 that he's conceded
all the dark squares Magus doesn't mind
it being down upon here because he's
gonna have active play on the dark
squares and create a bind is gonna be
threats this looks very promising even
of the
is saying this is about equal you better
you better find moves now as black
because your piece your pieces are gonna
come under pressure your squares are
gonna come under pressure
I would I would take this all day with
white like all day I wouldn't have any
worries what pawn down what are you
talking about like look at those squares
how do you guys see 5 B 6 rooks coming
to d1 it just so much play and and by
the way Jen your f4 we'll keep that on
top just in case we need it so Maurice
after a move like Bishop e6 developing
defending the pawn I know what you're
saying you want to clamp down big time
on the c5 and b6 squares if you go
Bishop e3 and black just continues is
develop and says ok recover your pawn I
got I got repeat on taps as fabbi I've
got kind of play I'm not I'm not just
sitting here doing nothing I don't see
your I don't see the pawn I'm not even
interested in ok like this I want to
just make sure I make a couple of good
moves
from this moment so maybe you need a D
file you have to be careful about one
thing and that is you're not going to g4
Knight g4 okay well I mean six has been
played by the way is it but yeah and is
it really play on one goal because Queen
a5 that's that's why I didn't like
actually Bishop to e3 immediately sorry
we do have Bishop e6 ov6 Haslam's like I
was thinking Queen e1 here Queen evening
Terrica move that's deep okay you you
you you're you're still trying to
control the dark squares but I mean I'm
I'm boring okay and now I'm just
developing and again Bishop e3 or Bishop
okay what about wait wait stop what
about Bishop d2 here let's go no it's d2
so you this against you an analysis
about 30 years ago yeah
when I played bar love I do the two
ideas a youngster yeah that's funny okay
go ahead and execute your plan again I'm
thinking that the half-open B file you
know you can kick me around I don't know
exactly where you're kicking me - yes
before is always a move okay Zoli
playing c5 so now rugby 1 etc I mean
what and it just goes yeah what are your
next what are your next few moves
although the engine like my rook d1 just
now
you don't play rook there how do we get
about 19 minutes for both players by the
way and then remind us it's game 25 it's
game 25 with the ten second increments
got it another key reminder for those of
you just tuning in garry kasparov will
be joining us during game two to talk
about the game the match and it's always
just such a thrill to have a goat on the
show right and particularly his strong
opinions about the final game of the
classical match which he was not on the
line or kramnik was on the line for that
like god I think Gary is watching this
right now and is is nervous on behalf of
Bobby because it's a this looks like
white like having five we just had a
trade of Queens okay okay what was a lot
like yeah Queen takes d1 which would
have been really nice for white giving
us the only open file as Magnus right so
instead Magnus was one to initiate the
trade after Bishop to e6 just a second
yeah so we were here we went Magnus went
Knight e4 and immediately traded by
Magnus that surprising to me because
that seems to my eyes to simply help
Savi's desirous control over the Defoe
well how do you mean f4 here yes because
I noticed that you can't play 97 you
can't move your knight and lock my
bishop in because f4 f5 would be
again a heart-stopping victory f4 I know
it's not but if you take on that for
that I'm happy with that Pandu on the
center-right and the potential for my
Bishop to explode so lady it's possible
here either way to place c4
I see three excuse me three three okay
and and release this bishop from prison
so that you can develop your pieces I
know yes you want to somehow figure out
a keep that pawn on the board
sure buddy your Bishop is coming on to
such heavy fire and IB d7 is an
essential move he instead played Bishop
to e3 going after those dark squares and
giving him the opportunity to play the
move not f4 now that we takes rook takes
we've got Bishop e3 unmoor very
positional treatment and we've got
Knight b8 to d7 as expected by Fabi
because he's just ready to bring his
rook to the half-open B file and I can
see that Magnus on a good day good solo
play at f2 f3 rook over to see one
Bishop drops back to f1 and I definitely
agree if white ever manages to play rook
c1 Bishop f1 and Bishop takes e4 the
pawn structure will be very favorable
for white okay rook b8 rook a v8 has
been played well after 97 we need to
move for white oh well we have okay I
got which what am I looking at which
word am i looking at the board on the
right is game so F every is all that is
on the board okay yeah so the reason I
like f3 is because we're gonna be Magnus
is gonna want to play Bishop f1 he's got
to keep the pawn on f3 protected and he
doesn't want to be menaced by Knight f6
to g4 so f3 is a prep move rook b8
reminding white like look I've got open
file for my rook and I'm a balling this
pawn on b3 and I'm eyeballing with b3 so
we're expecting rook on F 1 2 c1 rook
b3 and Faby says okay give me mine give
me your Bishop and I also want to x-ray
this pawn on f3 making it awkward for
you to play Bishop f1 King here and he's
played rook a c1 look on a to see one of
the interesting decisions being made
quite reflexively by the way that that
position with would that I suggest with
Queen e1 Bishop d2 your computer gave
compensation if you combine it with the
idea of Bishop before an F for Jenn's ID
keeping grinds on and going for the
break with F for that position you were
looking at saying compensation so that
was really an interesting way to keep
the Queen's on Magnus has decided he
doesn't want to keep Queens on he wants
to show superiority an endgame the
rookie is now on v3 attacking the bishop
after rook a c1 so we can catch up with
the board rook to b3 attacking that
bishop now to me when I look at this
position I see these two perf Lewis
Knights the knight on f6 and the night
on d7 that 906 is a problem for black
black is hungry for the moment when the
you could trade off one night and and
then reuse the d7 square for the knight
on f6 right because that piece is being
restrained right now by a pawn formation
you just can't do anything in fact how
many moves does he get to improve his
position if you look at this how would
you improve blacks position from this
moment let's say for example white
played King f2 I'm just gonna throw down
a move now White has easy moves as you
suggested yes he could move his rook to
d1 he can move his bishop back to f1 all
those moves are fairly unstoppable
exactly what is black supposed to do
right now what a block like just I'm
looking always want to know what are
your moves so that I can figure out how
to fight them what is black supposed to
do black would love to pick up that
night on their six and like drop it on
d4 somewhere OD 300 yes more ambitious
than mine go be beautiful to be able
that night that but where do you put
your bishop on e6 looks like it's stuck
there where do you put your rook on d8
you want to double on the B file
congratulations is when i donate for
where do you put your knight on D seven
it's no long long
moving to get the night to d4 it's hard
to figure out how to move right now for
likely black isn't in a why display look
by the way Magnus played rook to e1 rook
on instead look at the e1 keeping the
position stable and now we're I'm a
little surprised it wasn't kicking f2
maybe he saw some sacrifices on b2 in
case of Dublin default on the B file but
right now we have a situation
oh I know why you did of course because
he wants to play Bishop everyone
immediately and keep that going he's a
bishop everyone and take the pawn to c4
so now we have a situation where you
look at black and say okay you got the
extra pawn what are your next three
moves make some moves but where do you
put your pieces it's very hard to find
places for blacks be exact Black is
dominated right now right
especially the knight on a four versus
night on d7 the night on d7 really seems
to be stuck this guy's not going
anywhere because it's playing the role
of defender keeping the c5 and B six
squares actually beginning to get to the
point where aren't I supposed to play
rook b8 and c3 like let's let's try rook
b8 bishop f1 c3 a way of clarifying oh
yeah the Queen side before the ship
takes e4 lands absolutely I like this
plan I think necessary rook c3 right you
can't play nice e3 because of her B 293
hangs the pawn on b2 no at least I've
damaged the structure a ruby 3 now and
then a5 is necessary yeah it looks like
he's the worst
I've got ass yeah I managed to mess up
whites Queen site structure even so it's
the two bishops I mean White's still
better after for example rook a 185 well
the argument is that the dark square
bishop exact still strong it's very much
so and the problem is that a pawn is on
the board the Queen side pawns exist if
we could somehow trade off all those
pawns on the Queen side then we'd be
like
right now as far as wife's bloc is
concerned I'll give you my three on that
side for your two with that question
please can I somehow pull that off and
that's four versus four right and then
leave four versus four and your bishop
is not as dominating because it's a half
aboard then so that's something that
fabi's looking for is still pretty
balanced in the talk guys what about 14
15 minutes for each ply or each place so
they're keeping pace this was one of my
key concerns this morning when I woke I
woke up early way way before the alarm
and I was thinking that it's very
important for fabbi to keep pace on the
clock remember Game one when he started
the world championship match he was down
to the increments he nearly lost that
game by the way down a lot and even game
12 he was down a lot at the end it was
almost a three to one ratio 30 minutes
to write with nine moves me yes exactly
who's me yeah so Bobby has to state the
obvious a 10-second increment is not
enough to make and you know good
consistent moves absolutely in the same
way that the 31 is those 10 seconds they
get eaten up so fast you don't even on
the clock in that 10 seconds or that
goes by so very critical absolutely and
I did you know you and I would felt the
need to play the most c3 I checked it
with the engine the engine degree C
threes going to be essential rook rook d
b8 first and then throw out c3 so
essentially c3 that the interest willing
to play Knight takes c3 and now play B
takes c3 at the end of that in order to
give White's pawn structure the owner to
maintain the cohesion and White's pawn
structure so wrote BD 880 play Knight f8
I think he's got night I think I have
Knight FA da Mike is that is that what
or is it no Knight d6 ok so he tried to
improve the position of his knight on f6
as we were pointing that out the
superfluous night that's superfluous
night and I find a whole different track
those nights are not superfluous or
harmonious or I'm worried about the
night on g6 being in stable and be able
to hit it with a rook d1 or a knight c5
idea and I absolutely the only thing is
he's headed places and he's just hit the
hit the night okay but now we're not
hitting c-4 anymore so why can't we just
work tonight like beefy fibers because
I'm really worried that after night b5
does a 95 and be careful oh yeah and you
can take the pawn but then after Knight
takes pawn takes that's another Bishop
that suddenly is really tingly in that
line one is tough harmony of blacks
pieces of course you know I tried 95
let's try a knight b7 at least okay but
at least compared to the knight on d5
I'm holding on to c5 I'm holding on to
my rock on d8 but 96 leaves a very
dangerous impression to me yeah by the
way the engines giving 97 as the best
move by far anything else is worse for
blacks substantially but how do you play
Knight b7 right now as a human being
that's a hard move to play for so many
reasons
the Knight has no future on b7 what are
the other options 95 97 oh I get it I
get it but if you have to play like that
you'd rather go down a pawn in some kind
of other type position then have your
nights sitting on be too late for that
it wasn't the move for that to move
prior but yeah it really was
it really was right now I don't know
what else for him to me or our candidate
moves after after Brooke do you wanna
are we is it a is it allowed to move the
other night I don't think so because
there's gonna be a Bishop c5 right name
Knight FA Bishop c4 well Bishop c5 you
do have Knight d7 you're still kickin J
but there's also
should be six in 95 right rook parts of
that five rook takes me six Knight takes
T seven in the d6 at night hangs in the
end correct right so that's that wins an
exchange for sure this is not this is
not a team party position guys no this
is not a team fan because that would
just be totally lost so that means that
moving the knight is forced and moving
it back to e8 I mean that oh no that's
ultimate Robin there's no way no problem
besides losing time is it just doesn't
help your position in any manner
I wrote DT there's nobody five as well
there's no c3 either for you oh yeah we
already saw some line like this black
eye which mean I wish II thought longer
before playing might be six and came up
with her piayed it really was it really
was and will you feel again it's easier
for us to see from the side for sure but
it but nevertheless guys and I were both
like this is right now something like c3
and get all this stuff off of me right
now I need to get out of here
right that was his chance he tries to
improve his night he noted the bad piece
and tried to improve it but it didn't
really improve it this night on g6 is
now a new target and you can see in the
the fact that he's stopping here to
think about it
he thought he could probably get to b5
d4 and remember I made that point like I
want to improve my night and I wanted to
get to d4 also Yassir found seat d3 and
we're like oh that would even better but
you can't even get there but I saw the
d4 square Fabi sees the d4 square but
the timing was so important was so
critical that by doing it now you land
yourself in trouble because it's just
too soon it doesn't happen it's not
timely
he could still play for this by the way
the engines do give 95 sacking the pawn
and going down this ridiculous position
as possible
if land the knight on d4 and say you
know you want that then it's yours to
have I have a theory I think that maybe
I think that maybe the 98-96 maneuver
underestimated work on C 2 D 1 because
of course the work on anyone is
protecting the bishop on e3 good points
before right so maybe this is a yeah
this is a hidden move actually kind of
we strong move
yeah because as black you're sitting
there saying okay I've met your rook c1
bishop f1 idea by posting my knight on
d6 my bishop on e6 and then suddenly
this move rook d1 was like oh wait a
minute you're supposed to stay there and
keep attacking c4 so it's very possible
that rook c1 d1 just skip slip does
everything please now I'm just desperate
for black yeah well now I'm looking
under the computer for help Knight b7 is
a computer's first move and he's still
thinking right now but he doesn't want
to play it no it's a it's a human it's
not human no all right you look at it
you just cringe you write check out this
crazy line 95 which is very human right
so you got 95 Knight c5 now what are we
playing rugby - yeah 96 yep f e6 now we
have to pause because we got this and
this okay but go on
so Bishop c4 natural move yeah give me
the pawn give Knight d4 Knight David
forgot it yeah you're threatening Knight
takes a three check by the way correct
takes takes rook tip should I yeah I
should you interpolate then I'll play
King f8 and King ee7 so rate and now
King f7 okay all right all this you get
two and now that's your only move was
king h1 right and it looks like we're
going down this line it'd be incredibly
calculated but suddenly the move Knight
e5 shows up on the board and it's a draw
because Rudy 8 9 f3 check and you can't
play king h1 because it's made on h2 and
now we get a per pet how insane a line
is that but all the way back before you
double the rooks you should have played
Caitlyn don't play that because it's me
but before you IV line you sure that
blade King h1 so in this position after
rook takes King f7 the engines give King
h1 as clearly better
guys one what do we got 95 where is the
line we're going down the line 95 95
rook takes p2 on the board
yes we're good this is your position on
the right he now needs to he now needs
to 95 has been played and we're
expecting the movement thank you okay
we're low five rook takes b2 has been
played Knight takes c6 we're yeah this
place itself I would say Bishop takes c4
and as you say gen are threatening to
take on d7 taking on e6 94 looks box
forest Bishop takes pawn takes now this
one just Nets as an extra pawn and a
reckoning right Bishop takes a six check
King FA rook takes d4 that would be an
extra pawn in a rook ending but we're
we're looking at rook takes d4 King f7
and now thanks to this very unpleasant
pin on the D file the computer has this
well how to say it very crafty King h1
to get out of this combination of 95
takes f3 and the players are 96 Fe 6
moving on to our position this is the
position on the board right now 96 FV 6
and Bishop takes e4 that's amazing that
probably found this line but we know
that anyone who a 97 but he found the
same line and he thinks it's okay for
him as he marches forward in this
position now he needs to continue a 94
which might be expected does he actually
see this drawing line and will Magnus
find king h1 because of Magnus plays
king h1 suddenly rook d1 is coming and
your position is tied up forever
you're not moving anybody you just suck
along this eternal pin that feels really
bad it feels really really bad for black
and Magnus is scoping out of this
position I'm not sure if Fabiano
realizes and Aziz looking at the board
himself they
but if we have this line it's incredible
but we had I wasn't surprised that he
didn't play a 97 that booze looks so
yeah just counterintuitive so he decided
to go straight for a cinematic Knight d4
he's gonna get there give up this pawn
at the moment he's not he hasn't played
Knight d4 yeah down a pawn no yeah but 1
2 3 4 but he is down on the clock about
agent it's for Fabien 13 minutes from
Agnes of course this is a position we
had to struggle to find this plan maybe
594 now the problem with King f7 exactly
is what it must be the ship should be 65
yeah yeah that's the problem is there
better is that we've got this terrible
pin and there isn't any - wait a minute
chief I might be four rook d4 okay yeah
that cat that wins a piece
yeah let's note that line by the way
Bishop did 494 with the same idea of
Perpetual checks don't take the rook
knight takes f3 will be a perpetual
check again we can just play rook takes
d4 returns before we keep the line go
take a look at this pawn takes Bishop d8
yeah
and what's 95 with a dual threat of
Knight Bishop you to d3 Bishop do you
wan that looks like a showstopper does
it is it because of d2 just one just
work f1 right and indeed we do have the
move takes on d4 now that the players
are catching up to our analysis but but
that word analysis is not is not good
for a fabbi
know oh he's there was there yeah king
f7 well anymore
no there's Bishop takes east six check
that's a pawn up in a rook and pawn on
you although I'm not happy about the
real component you mean as my king
it's stuck on the first ring how do you
get a pawn up after King f8 Bishop takes
a six check yeah if a great XD 495 no
because you're hanging your rook on d8
with check oh you don't get to play
Knight takes f3
but if I play King II is that an extra
but that's extra pawn oh it's a pass
upon well I have four
- yeah on the kingside four versus two
that's two extra pawns you have a two
versus one on the queenside the problem
is I don't want that king of party game
because I'm afraid that my king on g1 is
a little too passive right so let's see
that line because he's thinking about
both of them he's we know about the rug
d4 line you have to find king h1 in that
line but anybody should be six King f8
right d4 I can't check so this is a pawn
to the good for white but we're just a
little bit worried that thanks to thee
hold on what I want to sack this rook I
just see what happens you said it would
check but if I play 95 you take and I
play King what's your next move here
correct and if I take your rook Europe
upon your saying and you're satisfied
with that position I guess you should be
yeah so you're not you're not up a rook
you just you're up the pawn with clarity
with some clarity a beep ah you're a
pawn but it seems like Maggie is deep in
the tank as he just vodka Nick takes d4
and Bishop takes c6 try I think I would
I would priority play rook takes d4 in a
in a bullet game because my instinct
would be you know let's let's bring this
pin back into the position now depending
on how much time I had in the rapid game
I would take a careful look at that rook
nd I would the rook ending is is correct
but better for white for sure but that
active rook on this ran absolutely a
statement so let's let's take a look at
this work ending Bishop takes c6 check
King f8 because we haven't looked at it
rook d4 King isse Evan which carries
with a dual threat of 95 so you can't
just you can't just drop your Bishop
back let's drop let's drop it back
somewhere like c4 for example our h3
right so 95 comes with a thud and
suddenly the idea of taking on f3 your
rook is actually hanging on d4
the rook is actually defended on d8
and you're crying right now as white got
murdered so in this position after rook
takes d4 King e7 time to take time to
take on d7 takes and takes and takes and
now assess this position there's a
passed pawn sitting on e4 but black has
a passed pawn on c5 and active rook on
b2 and the threat of rook b3 at the
moment as well to win the pawn back this
is something to judge Magnus is going to
feel pretty confident that he'll win
this endgame with it so Lee has passed
pawn on e4 is that I don't know that
this is that easy no my gut instinct
says the drawing chances are higher than
whites winning chances and that from the
current position I would probably fall
back on Luke takes d4 but he has in its
great lesson for everyone at home about
critical moments Vladimir Kramnik was on
our show the other day saying this is a
critical moment and I wouldn't be
surprised if Bobby thinks for for 10
minutes out of his remaining 20 in this
situation Magnus is taking his biggest
tank of the game he's been thinking for
almost 5 minutes and that's quite a lot
in a rapping game but if you think about
it it makes so much sense because on
both crossroads you're making a very
communal decision my position do you
want to go which one gives you more
chances for the win yes I see so but
still I mean he's got to make a move
right the key is finding king h1 and
realizing that that yeah and long term
gray fur yeah that's gonna be the magic
moment if he finds that kudos to the
world champion for showing just how
great but he is because that's a
fantastic move now but you know I would
sorry to say I would really really want
to resist playing King of course I think
I would probably find rook e3 a lot
easier to play than king h1 because I
want to double the rough trail and I
just want to avoid that 95 trick that 95
takes F I don't know unpin so let's try
King e7 and then I pin and then I get my
W pinned me along the D line that's
right so I got I have no knight move
because you take and I gotta take the
rook and you
have that perpetual oh this looks great
this is wonderful I mean this looks a
lot less very human that's a very human
it but that means I've Agnes actually
has like multiple choices which
increases his chances of craps going in
for the sign yeah Luke takes d4 yeah we
have multiple ways to deal with this 95
idea well I you know it's what you're
saying he's got to weigh those
advantages and if you've got rookie
three on tap if you see rookie three or
king h1 you're saying oh man I really
like being able to double up and keep I
grandmasters love to pin their opponents
and tie them up so that they reduce the
opponent's options and Magnus's approach
in this match has been risk averse right
so anything that you know anytime you
can tie up your opponent I'd expect
Magnus to go for rook takes d4 okay
check recheck this out because that
looks so compelling but there's a
long-term problem 7 yeah if you look at
the line with rook II D 3 going to your
lineup that's rookie D 3 well I just
went rook takes T I went rookie 3 what
do you want a king e7 o king e7 okay
rook III to d3 yes Maurice yes and rook
C to rook seat I know I looked at this
move and I thought it was ridiculous but
the agent saying this is the best try
because you've got ideas of undermining
my bishop so I'm gonna fall for it
Bishop takes pawn and now a and now c5
whoa here we go from counter play
counter play rook comes down to zz4 whoa
yeah time to upset the applecart now
black has a rambunctious pawn running
down the board he does indeed and and
you are hanging well I'm still pinning I
got you tie it up dude route d4 is just
c3 like there's no tie up we got one
clear plan we're pushing are pushing
baby that's our only counter play push
the bond until you prove otherwise we're
pushing our bond that's a remarkable La
Nina and by the way be careful cuz 95 is
back on the storyline
that could come into play but it should
be five right now I'll play Bishop to c4
and I'm gonna play for gift me upon
Bishop to c4 Maurice gift route c1 check
okay I'm not sure but King G - you got a
place C - Dead on c6 now it suddenly
began I just gotta ask you one thing
though what's wrong with the clock
minutes for Magnus eight minutes for
Fabiano you guys actually get to finish
her points and we still haven't
he has to fight if he finds the king h1
move then he doesn't deal with any of
this nonsense he played Bishop e6 check
he's going for the endgame of course he
is now he decided it's time to just bail
out and go for this position because he
couldn't find a way to maintain all the
advantages he didn't see king h1 it was
in the rookie three line he probably may
have seen but decided too much play and
now he's decided let me go for something
that I saw instantly he saw Bishop e6
and Rudy for instantly but he wanted
more he didn't want this endgame he
wanted more from it now he is stuck
playing his endgame hopefully enough for
that C pawn is still counter play
without question Murray's because we we
know that rook endings where your pawn
up as nice as they are if the other side
has an active rook or a passer the
counter play in these rook endings even
when you're a pawn up tends to be enough
for the side the weaker side to draw the
game and then it's like oh no yeah in
fact in fact their positions where if
you are if a guy attacks your pawn
instead of playing some passive rook
move you say take the pawn I don't care
let me get my rook go to the 7th and
this is what black has achieved in this
position not not by normal state of
affairs but by default he's here
now active King active rook past c-pawn
epon will be blockaded white does have a
weak pawn on a3 so you will have to pay
attention to that as well I mean black
has clear lines of character play
despite being a pawn down now let's make
this point that King h1 move yeah that
he had to play not only see but also
play yeah that was so counterintuitive I
do not care what engine you have looking
at that you go oh yeah just play KH 1
you play King H 1 I'm not burying my
King in the corner like that that was
not an easy move at all - fine yeah
rookie 3 was much more natural but
giving crosses in ability to see very
deeply he started seeing those lines he
started realizing the C pawn was flying
down the board Russy - was a tricky move
fancy 4 and boom boom suddenly there's
big counter play so Magnus had to
analyze all that all those dangers see
counterintuitive moves again even if he
saw them to actually play them very hard
and now only 3 minutes on his clock does
Magnus have to 8-bit is by Fabi home and
this is an easier position by far from
obviously for Fabi to play no question
now a check on the board attacking his
King looks like he should step towards
played rook t1 check
yes rook t1 it looks like he should go
to the e-file and not let this pawn just
fly down the board but he could
theoretically go to the C file or you
don't forget if you go king c7 which I
would prefer because I would like to
support the C pawn after E 5 you could
get the rookie behind bry than that for
and I'm threatening King f1 with other
nasties I'm a little scared
yeah maybe as much as you would like to
hang around your C pawn and support its
yes what's more likely in this game a
draw or a win for Magnus if you had I
think the draw has a higher probability
in my view than a win because already a
draw
and because of the passive king that
it's currently stuck and the fact that I
can see Candice England is clear I can
see and the weak pawns for white you got
to deal with this a three-pointed on the
clock and the clock so many very
significance by the way yes or yes was
it was a tart Irish or talk to Carlo who
said all work endings addressed Irish
terrorists chest like music has the
power to make men happy yes and women
whoa there will be a very happy again
Bobby if you could pull off this drawer
he is twenty actively give him credit
despite the fact that he was going to be
worse in them in those lines night be
fine that night be five line which just
look if Magnus had found the moves it
would have been real problems for him
but he said you know I'm not going
passive against this guy I go passive
he's gonna squeeze that Magnus loves to
squeeze he turns into an orange
real quick not without position once
again two minutes on the clock seven
minutes for Fabi seven or two and
ticking three to one edge and we think
it's we got to move f4 right Jeff for
that looks like we've got yeah okay so
Magnus is putting his majority on the
kingside to use and he's eyeballing me
five and rook check there's a king to f5
okay so let's see it so we'll start with
the obvious c5 for counterplay purposes
right we're going to go d6 let's get the
live board up please because I'm afraid
moves are gonna get put in the light
okay so now we have this we I'm
expecting c5 what else well there's one
of their is after this pawn not that way
I would I would have done it with rook
b3 to try to make you pass it with your
rook well you know your King gets
released but maybe maybe I'd have
something there but you have he five
that I'm worried about well what well
let's start activity let's start active
let's go active as you said it see d5
now rook here King here then II five
check okay dude let's see if I can can
guess man
says a concept here he gets to move his
pawn with a check for up and he gets to
check you okay so now here you've got to
take a deep breath and ask yourself how
active do I want to be because I want to
be active well okay I just want to lose
my game lose the game because I belong
I've got a winning loot I've got a
winning threat East seven is a winning
threat be correct if you drop your rook
back I've got rook d800 can I have three
I will play check not a nice guy not a
nice guy and now King g4 you play rook
e1 correct and then I cry okay and then
you start crying because this guy is
really fast all right so that means okay
so check is a big problem because of it
because of e-cigs
although no okay I will the way we did
it is from the current position I went F
for c5 I attacked the pawn the King
defended the pawn I played a fight with
a check followed by another check
followed by e6 every key to here let's
make a move rook eat and boy Tommy's got
a look at this he's spending all his
clocks I'm here the mercury went high
k3 I'm a rookie three excuse me rookie
one okay so one was a great movie so now
the issue becomes can he get
can he get you to push the pawn I think
you got to drop your rook back right now
right here I'm sorry to say I think it's
time to bring right wait working B 6 e 7
or e 6
I got rook e1 check the tree yeah no
you're right I think this book has to go
back oh well then you have to count on
your king and C pawn doing the job right
your bridges Bobby who's now in the tank
guys and I don't know I was a critical
position obviously hugely on team 5e big
believer but I'm more feeling like 5050
now I mean obviously him thank you but
few minutes it shows a nervous sign for
everybody like hey II find that you're
showing as Wow yeah he did place he
fight baby that is that at the draw of
15 that it's a win for Maggie there's
always that 1% chance yeah exactly
something weird a blunder a rook or
whatever it is so c5 and again it's only
a 10 second bonus these players for the
last two weeks have been getting 32nd
bonuses look boy adjustment well I
wouldn't be surprised if in the training
period for the last couple teams they've
played some games kind of get used to it
and the Blitz to the five three on the
outside chances was it was a car yakin
who said in an interview and you in
chess that when he got to the tie rates
he realized that he had prepared for the
Blitz but not the rapid when you create
a lot of blitz training times but not
rapid guys by the way the game and
whoopsy to the game is afoot the reality
is now by the way Magnus has played he's
allowed this c-pawn to be real counter
play the pawn can go to c4 can go to c3
the route can't just start gobbling up
things and he can't also figure out an
easy way to get his Ebron going so black
has real counter play game it is not a
three result still a two result confused
by the rook d5 rookie five Center 41 you
life yeah I think he thought that c4
rook c5 and he said oh by the way the
engines like that also the C points a
seed for black it's fine for black
because the pawns going really fast this
game is all about that counter free on
the C pawn right now this move rook c2
Magnus is in the tank is that true is it
time to bring our King over to deal with
this problem but no you might have to
give up your age pawn to pull that off I
understand and you haven't made any real
progress yet well I'm I'm just saying
that h4 has been played well the moment
gen says is it a three result game is
when I start as when I started thinking
to myself well I'm gonna take that H
pawn off the board
hurry h4 is on the board Jen and again
what's the clock time sorry - one and a
half three minutes for Fabi one and a
half Agnes Oh or on the board he should
be very rich and game with the world
championship hanging in the balance my
good boys and girls hold on to your hat
so this heavier heads but it's got to go
now for the c4 idea it's mandatory
it's simply mandatory now of course
after c4 fabbi has to look at rook a 5c3
rook takes a6 check when he's two pawns
down in a rook ending but guess what
that pawn on c3 is huge
he's just threatening to go rook d2 and
c2 and he's played it yeah they did look
at this line look at this line
talk about a three result game suddenly
oh yeah get it rook a five was playable
rookie five west plate was playable well
you have to be really careful about what
is or is no it was not played f5 check
out of five but you have to worry about
that C pawn because he's the white the
black king can come towards your rook
and prevent you from getting behind this
pawn king d7 and suddenly you're running
oops
what's going on I can't get behind the
pawn suddenly blacks on top
yeah so that was a lie Magnus avoided
with my shack
very important line very important what
isn't q7 force now King a seven looks
box and then maybe II five Maurice so
that only after c3 to play rook c5 again
these pawns on King as six was played
here Aaron's oddity is indeed the most
accurate move Bobby has found slowing
down the epon keeping his King on f6 for
the moment and the engines are giving no
advantage barely any rookie would
reasonable position note c5 yes what c5
play nice you just play C 3 and the
engine saying this position is equal
really yeah is after c3 g4 he played an
H oh oh he played h5 guys he's I mean
all the accuracy is oh I think h5 is a
good move because G fool happy forest
because then he would
looks very human but maybe there was
some kind of way to pick up all the
pawns that the if the engine like that
maybe there's some kind of way to pick
up all the pawns after g4 what's very
strange
yeah h5 this is still fine grace is
still fine for Maggie two and a half for
Fabia
this position is still good as long as
five he doesn't blunder as long as he
sees the position clearly he is fine
King f1 is on the board it's it's
absolutely mandatory in my view for
whites came to come on over and deal
with this past pump and now c3 right
where are we expecting anything other
than c3 or maybe we are we could play
well I don't know c3 is so natural
exactly exactly so King f1 on the board
and Maurice what's the engines top
triple zeros in this position by the way
C 3 a 4 a 5 C 3 a 4 a 5
kingi 1 let's say then and then simply
rotate soon rook a - alright I not it
you don't touch the a pawn don't even
think I and you're hitting this eforp ah
so those made the point if we played
rook c3 oh boy oh boy
after King F 1 we have rook c3 on the
board yes hopefully that's also equal
but it has been played roots III he is
very much still in this game is black
yeah but he's not playing necessarily
the easiest move King g2 is on the board
a cue that one the engines really don't
like King G - correct because now you
could take the pawn on a3 okay kingi to
rook a3 rook c4 and after king e5 what
you got oh yeah what's up doc I mean
this is this looks like it's gonna be a
dragon that one is a little bit fast on
me I'm thinking king takes e4 tanks you
have proved it yet no but how do you get
away from sorry
how do you get away from my checks Jack
yeah how do you get away from these
checks
sooner or later your horns gonna hang
I'm gonna hang out over on h3
I was black with 45 45 seconds okay let
me update my current position yes
captured on 83 he did and he captured on
c4 and he did play king e5 so now we're
looking at right and King takes c4
yes natural moves yes now we're seeing
so the check the the key is can you
leave and looks like we got working
staff and check he set up position on
the right that is a live board I know he
played rookie 7 check he didn't take on
g7 it looks like you played working 7
check indeed and now now sessi is giving
a win white white is now winning the
game he's gonna take the H pawn as well
as everything on this board so if you go
okay we have this position are you
saying Brooke e7 check was a really good
move
yes not cuz it's forcing my king to move
so you can't do okay to check that was a
clear answer correct it is now lost this
position is lost for blind
what's the difference after rook takes
pawn why was if this was if this is
Winnie now why wasn't winning after just
taking on g7 right away why is Rick a to
took such a big deal if I came looking
age three I think the difference is gen
that the king is on a forced to f5 so in
this position he could play for room
takes f5 would be okay he forces the
King to get to the f5 Square with this
beautiful international which is really
easy to miss I missed it rookie 7
checked I mean I was just taking the
pawn without consideration but we have a
game right now
rook John g5 your H pawn is dropping
your if no way of dealing with these
pawns
Bobby is now in a loss he has been game
well it did play after
who's that Magnus played in the game
work to yuan and rookie 7 check but
Fabia so this is other ways this is all
this is a Fabien other ways game not
playing with c3 not playing aggressively
with c3 instead of not allowing White's
King to come up the board that was where
he lost the game we're in it twice he
you mean with c3 yes in the middle game
and in the yes exactly that way you're
saying that after this rook c3 in line
he was actually lost he was a lot well
Luke takes a three rookie 7 check was
probably losing so where was our last
moment well let's see we can talk about
that later
yeah let's just keep a look at this
board right now there's no way to stop
because the King will you see this pawn
blacks fab ease pawn will go to a2 and
you'll constantly be looking for an
opportunity to play rook Jiwon check and
make a queen
so what White's King is going to do is
actually gonna step in front of the Jeep
on ok the king will come to g4 then
white will play rook check and he will
nurse his H pawn up the board and this
pawn on 8th or will not give counter
play when White's King is in front
that's one way yes or no way I mean how
do you stop the pawns from marching just
g4g 5h4 check you first made you go back
to input I just keep marching okay this
is math okay great no there's nothing to
do your rook can't move because okay -
happens all the time I like my King in
front of the pawn to escort the guy the
ball agreed but I'm just saying that
this yeah it's bad it's not like you
have to think now because there are
multiple ways to win Bobby blue this
rook ending in this position we think
Jin that once we saw the move King F one
way back here this was the moment that
fabbi well first of all h5 apparently
wasn't needed the immediate do not need
hpz
easy I understand that c3 was the key
that c3 was the key and then after I
think it was king e1 a5 a4 somehow we
yes position I was not easy to see by
the way but works III is sympathetic -
so you're saying work t3 is actually
lost because of that any between move
yes but that was the moment of no return
that was right that this is this is it
right here Magnus all that entire line
or just assess some I think he's just
playing yeah he was make a move and he
right they did here it was like the
accidental victory you know I mean
because everybody was looking at rook G
says that's what happens when you have a
better position sometimes you get a no
victory that's the queen of getting the
better position in blitz right that's
right
but yeah so just I mean obviously we're
on Team Pavia but not to minimize Magnus
is fantastic recognition of an
opportunity resume moment out of a great
game in my view with the other thing the
other thing that he did the other thing
that Magnus did is you see why he's so
great at rapid he played very
practically in 20 when he sat on the
board he said I don't know that I can
win that other position that looks a
little sharp that moves look a little
confusing even if he saw King H once
actually play it he said I don't know
about all that
let me go into something where I have no
losing chances but I do have winning
chances let me keep some time on my
clock let him find all the right moves
I'm not the one losing so this is a draw
it is what it is he doesn't need maximal
results probably had to play perfectly
down the pawn and he was doing really
well but he missed this couple of
moments to be very active with the c3
move and that's all it took for the
world champion to say no no you got to
play better chess
if you're gonna survive these end games
and Magnus showed why he is indeed the
champion well now here he is going to
move g4 by the way everybody just as
Marissa saying you can play g5 and rook
check get that I'm thinking king h4 King
g5 put the King in front of the pawns
and then get the check is over that way
and he has played King H for the king
will five the king is coming to g5 the
rook will come to this and fabbi will go
down and this first game we thought it
we had this conversation yesterday
Maurice and we we were both emphatic in
our belief that games 1 and 2 were
absolutely vital
yes and we see this position on the
board now game two comes after game
wanyan yes got the white people but the
brush is on now oh he's got a win one he
had to win one anyway so I never thing
plus one is enough if you lose by plus
one it's like but you had to win one
anyway exactly so if you don't win the
one then of course you're supposed to
lose I just feel like this game to me
I'm not that shocked that man is one
because that opening look kind of brutal
the size of the advantage from magneri
oh don't blame the opening he was a c6
be 586 that makes a very strange
impression guys he had multiple ways and
I was all-star just targeting the
opening yeah that's the open you know I
do feel that it put him in a tough
position it seemed like a lot of fun for
Magnus what are you talking about it
lots of minutes on the clock and a
rookie drawing working for an ending
that you pray for that but a survivor
phenomenally accurate play after not
totally accurate just good enough to get
to this position in fab you ain't good
thoughts
yeah but fabbi was down a par and here
we see the game by the way white
actually got two extra pawns Fabi
playing on we know that there are some
you know incredible stalemate type
situation yeah they were basically
playing on anger but okay two extra
pawns for but let's just put it this way
it wasn't what far it wasn't what Fabi
said and Magnus there's a line that the
first game of the rap is and no I just
believe that Bobby did not get what he
wanted out of this game it put him in a
very tough situation from the get-go I'm
with you why why don't you see it that
way
look here's the deal sure you want to
get a good position as we see there
Magnus has done the best he could
possibly do by winning the very first
game right away and putting the pressure
on the Challenger now in must-win
situations maybe not this next game but
certainly in one of the next three and
getting certainly getting also white
twice he's got to hope that that's gonna
be enough but let's make this clear this
is my opinion on this guy okay sure
here's the deal it sir if I give you the
black position and I said you're gonna
have black you're gonna get and this is
what I'm mailing in for you yeah so sir
I'm gonna give you a rook and pawn
ending well you have an active rook and
a passed pawn and an active King more
active rook Pat more active King
centralized King your opponent's king is
cut off you're down a pawn but you have
three times the guys time and he's at a
minute and a half and you got black yeah
how do you feel about those bot that
that situation for yourself very good
exactly I agree if that's what you
that's what you play for agree you say
give me a rook important ending where
you're my I'm active and I should draw
this position I just need to find the
right moves you you beg for that if you
have black that's that's you design if
that's what you said this is what you're
gonna get you say yeah yeah bring it
I'll show you what I know so that's what
I'm saying I don't think Bobby I think
Bobby had to engineer some
shark-infested waters indeed to get to
that situation there but once he got
there he's supposed to say I know this
is your own I will tell you he walks on
stage right now saying I know that was
drawn I spoiled it I spoiled it somehow
I feel badly about myself for not
holding that position he's not thinking
he was lost he knows but putting
yourself in that kind of tight rope you
got is what you can attain hundreds or
four just like you got a lot better I
think for most of the black games he
didn't get such a big disadvantage in a
matter that's irrelevant that's
irrelevant I think it really that's
completely irrelevant ah it's that's
completely the past is done okay play
present this
you get this position I think all his
handlers will say you get a position
where you're working you're down in the
rookie part ending where you're Brooke
is more active Nick is more active you
got a passport you got to draw that game
oh sure but how is it irrelevant that he
did way better with black and the
regular match I mean of course like if
you got one of this position in in the
match we would be like wow magnets got
so much with the white pieces right I
mean we had time to look at all those
variations yeah well first of all again
that rook ending I really think that
Maurice is right 2800 supposed to hold
that I think time factors rapid chess
the moment you still think it was more
likely if we if for instance if we ran
that exact situation a hundred times
with those same two players I think in
Georgia the time is gonna be a draw I
agree with you but I'm feeling like it
would be 60/40 I don't think it would be
like ninety ten oh no no I think the
courts four versus two majority was very
very serious here's where I have a
problem with Maurice and saying about
the opening because literally from the
opening black was under pressure and
fabbi got into a position where he had
to show some real you know nifty nimble
moves just to get to that rook ending we
were looking at rook takes d4 King f7
and we king h1 was a computer move rook
III and we were looking at this position
and this was really you know super
difficult for black black had to play
find all kinds of only moves Jen I think
fabbi will not be happy with his opening
he just got into a position which in my
opinion was hard and by the way we're
gonna have a very special guest I'm not
actually I'm hearing though that he
learned that we might not get Gary so
but I'm sure yeah but I sure will be
stunned
yeah the way it said happening to you I
just want to say this that we're getting
enormous numbers of interview requests I
was on the radio
yesterday with Rex we went downtown to
go on a radio program it was amazing oh
yeah today I had a another radio
interview just before we coming on the
show is coming out of the woodwork oh
it's awesome and I actually saw that
this morning on The Today Show a friend
of mine yes Today Show in New York so
really do mcveigh she's a member of the
US chess women's community she's like an
awesome person she's actually a
volunteer at the World Championship so
they in know in London but you couldn't
make it for the tiebreaks I guess she
was hoping he missed that there would be
a winner before that but yeah they
interviewed her in the Today Show and
she was talking about how impactful it
would be for us chess if Fabiana were to
win the world championship of course
this is not a good start yes I'm not
gonna lie absolutely very very bad start
but luckily he does get the white pieces
in the next game exactly and we are
watching the highest-rated World
Championship in history as we have the
two top players in the world facing off
and while you look at the quality of the
games you can see that strength seeping
from the Meuse carlton number one player
in the world carolina number two player
in the world this game guys if it was in
the classical I'm feeling like Carolina
would have defended because it's all
been about amazing defense in this match
but that's the problem this incredible
zwischen bug rookie 7 on the ten-second
increment but look at some of these
others yeah we've got a Carlson on on
with the second-closest but look at how
that it's like it's a creep each year
every pass in two years it's like the
averages creep higher and higher and
higher it's been a very consistent
almost logarithmic all the way up to
this highest average 28 33 I love that
graphic of 1972 that was the year that I
got involved in chess I was attracted
with Fischer Spassky that was a number
one versus number two for the time
comparing all Gelfand for example was
number two 20 Kramnik when he played in
2008 was number six and so on so number
one versus number two I mean I'm
I'm crazed money but I'm totally blown
away by the the level of play in this
match let's go to prize money as we saw
that because of the draw that we had two
days ago they're actually playing for a
little bit less money if the matches
just decided I'm sorry the winner gets a
little bit less money yeah the match is
decided by Tyreke games
the winner gets fifty five percent of
the 1 million euro purse as opposed to
sixty percent why decided if we had a
decisive winner in game 12 they would
have once six hundred thousand euros and
the runner-up four hundred thousand now
it's five hundred and fifty thousand
euros to the winner that's right but
this is all about the title retaining
the title it's the thing that comes and
the prestige of course it comes with the
championship title Jennifer I'm kinda
the thing I feared most I want to put a
dike that as occurred in Game one well
hey I'll tell you this grandma came on
the line and said in game 12 it couldn't
be going worse for Fabi the opening is
terrible
the clock situation is terrible but that
would turn out for Fabia's magnet
surprisingly offered a draw good
so here we are today couldn't have
started worse right Magnus wins the
first game right so can Bobby surprise
us all and come back in this match what
do you think he's white he's got it some
dazzling advantage of why I was looking
for you to control me let's look at some
things right here exactly let's try to
use an instruction for our audience this
end game is the one we were talking
about right this is the one when you get
an endgame
that's supposed to be drawn you'd know
in your heart you've done everything
you're supposed to do you're clamped is
rook down even as pawn structure h5 may
not have been the best way to play but
is definitely a good way to play he was
in the right direction you've got this
you're only down upon in a rook and pawn
ending when you know you've got the
activity you've got the rope so what is
the most important thing we know about
rook upon anything stay active
stay active active active keep the guys
King cut off
don't let him get any progress so in
this position I'm gonna give you one
line here he played rook c3 that was
already wrong direction
releasing releasing the king from prison
this is not what you want to do all
right so that's mistake big mistake
number one thinking that you're down
upon this is a problem Tigran Petrosian
used to say when you sacrifice upon the
late great world champion from Armenia
said when you sacrifice a pawn don't act
like you sacked it act like you don't
act like you lost it
act like you sacked it right if I gave
you the pawn you got the wrong big deal
I get it on purpose I'm not greedy to
get my pawn back that's not the first
thing I'm after this move looks like
it's trying to get his pawn back but
guess what he doesn't even get his pawn
back he's exchanging an a pawn for AC
pawn that looks like a bad idea I mean
why would you do that rook c3 King g2
okay three
that was not what you wanted I remember
time-pressured well the circumstances
all that we understand you made this
mistake but just from a real technical
standpoint that's not what you want to
do rooks III was a mistake c3 and said
now white is frozen white right it's
like stuck this pawn is going down the
board his work can't just leave his rook
if his rook checks then this King
marches up the board and comes into the
position so he can't do that so he's
making sure this guy's cut off at the
moment King e1 now rook G 2 rooks III
King e5 check out this line even giving
up a second pawn to get this position is
still fine for black here the activity
of the King the rook is cut off this
rook is super passive your pawns about
to be attacked if you play King f1 rook
a to again an incredible position guys
where black is saying it's all about
keeping your king cut off and keeping my
rook active and keep my pieces active
activity and rook endings is the key
even down upon even here down to pawns
and I'll follow the line rook c7 now we
saw before and it doesn't even matter
what you play now this rook check
doesn't do anything because you think f3
suddenly becomes rut ro juicy even king
fi by the way is playable believe it or
not but King it why would we even play
that when we have this move on the board
I'm gonna show you King at 5 just to
show you and then rook takes G's g7 rook
g5 check King e4 rook takes and we're
back on f3 again and now your rook check
drops this guy and pawns are hanging
and it's again a draw it's all about
staying active and this is what I was
saying and I see yeah so you'd be like
yeah that's what we do work upon endings
yeah that's what he had to do at the
engineer with those eight or so minutes
on his clock to understand that activity
trumped material especially rook
important innings he knows that it's
just the pressure of the moment time
situation all of it cascaded on him and
Jen to your point that he'd been
defending so long and you had to keep
defending you're right that cost him but
I was just in shock I mean I was really
impressed by Magnus is playing that game
earthy Juan was an awesome move it
really was 96
yeah that was really really good rookie
seven that was a beautiful hidden gem
kudos for Magnus there but again we talk
about creepy moves of the Queen because
you're used to spectacular long moves
with Queen but sometimes those little
cream mousse here was the the creepy
crook moves just move the rook one
Square and just Queen takes da to just
trading off Queens by Magnus there was
something about his control and
understanding well that was simply
better but I completely agree with Hugh
Maurice when you get in that position of
a rook and pawn endgame and you're
playing bullet chest you're playing c3
and rook a to and king e5 kinds of moves
automatically because you just have to
stay active and like you say you know
don't play like your pawn down play like
you sacrifice the pawn for active play
and that was a very very big difference
put it in perspective for us okay
obviously on the same line Bobby's been
playing I'm thrilled about this from the
not only at the Fabi fan perspective but
even the fan perspective in general
because we're gonna get an exciting game
Bobby's gonna get a chance now to you
know get a dynamic game like we've had
in all of the white position since he's
been playing the open Sicilian exactly
no more raw salimos those raw salimos
with Bishop b5 were just not bringing
home the bacon and the 97 move was
played as well game 12 we're 97 and
games 8 and 10 Magnus was in trouble
after an IP a night b8ed and fabbi
dictated the pace those two games the
opening but 97 the opposite was the case
resident right okay so after 97 forest
IG 6 though also in my day c2 c3 was
considered dangerous but see for now
Knight f5 was the old move to in game 12
Knight g6 was played are we up to date
with the plone not at all we're still
going they're going to download Bishop
d7 and not h4 but Queen a4 right Queen a
for Bishop d7 Queen before this was game
12 and Magnus did not play the move
Queen b8 in game 12 he played Bishop f5
but in this game he did play Queen me he
did play queen bees okay because I
actually thought queen bee 8 was a
better move and after queen bee 8 we got
h4 h5 yeah ok I'm in Bishop to e3 Bishop
to e3 developing ethic this nighttime b5
bothers black a lots of a 63 and a 5
ok 3 a 4 really Wow he won Queen David
won mm-hmm 70 h 5 yet g 3n g 3 okay and
I think fabbi is gonna be happy about
the outcome of this opening not about
game 12 because here his play is much
easier he's going to put his king on on
the Kings side he's castling short is
white and he's not putting his king on
the Queen side I like it and I think
that's a lot easier and considering the
match situation he's got to be thrilled
right absolutely double-edged position
you need to win Magnus is gonna have to
find some pretty crafty defensive you
know okay let's see what do you
recommend I'm saying
yeah I don't want to I don't know I
don't know I don't want to decide with
Fabi and just give all right one way
right let's be clear it loses this game
the match is over
clear over it yeah so a sharp position
unless he's better yeah unless you can
say clearly better just having a sharp
position ain't enough hmm
all right a sharp position Magnus way I
said yeah let's go I've seen you in
rapid chess I know myself in rapid chess
I don't have to defend and draw it black
right I can just keep playing and if you
get a bad position and I'll play you -
oh you're done you're done so let's not
get too happy until he starts
controlling this game I'm not getting
happy I might say yeah on balance
position it's interesting but also white
says I got this position on lockdown
there's no there's no happiness in his
heart this his heart is beating fast and
the pressure is on and he must win one
of these three games he doesn't have to
win this one he doesn't have to go all
out to win this one he just needs to
keep playing the position as though it's
a walk in the park day like Kramnik said
don't worry about the situation just
play your best chess look for what you
want to do and let the rest take care of
it you start getting all the emotions
involved you know I mean obviously
Magnus played this position not like
Magnus said oh let's just play a boring
position let's play one of those dead
positions where I can make a draw Magnus
said bring it I'm gonna play this sharp
position against you so far in this
position you got nothing against me
prove it now and if you try to prove it
too hard you lose the match is over - oh
you ain't coming back from that okay
it's not gonna happen let's not get
happy folks it's just obvious math I
mean I'd rather have a 50% chance of win
and picture % chances of lose here draw
just good at the short match chances
yeah the position is sharp in double
edge and I I agree both players are you
know really really well prepared I'm
just saying that Bobby is a fabian
compared to game 12
much easier for white to play this than
in game 12 castling long walking into
those attacks I'm not any of that I only
wear argumented played by madmen c8 okay
eyeballing the pawn on c4 making Bishop
g4 possible trying to grab some white
squares that's right because I mean I'm
gonna play Bishop e2 and I'm gonna grab
this pawn on on h5 and I think Magnus
you're gonna get that book it's gonna
say look before you grab the pawn on h5
let me at least induce you to play the
move b3 so he played queen c8 right yes
and we're expecting Bishop e2 that's an
automatic and now the question is is
black going to a black place for f5 n f4
he's got to do it with castles I think
you can't just play f5 and allow Bishop
takes h5 when the knight on g6 will be
unprotected
so castles is forced right Murray says
that the engines number one is Bishop g4
as the National which induces the move
f3 Wow okay just a second I I'm a pawn
grubber you know that so I'm just
looking at Bishop takes pawn takes and
Knight takes a for Queen takes e4 for
Czech Queen d2 you've got Queenie four
also to escape trick trickery yep okay
so I somehow reluctantly I'm playing at
three but it's funny Gary didn't like
that exactly I understand why though
because you created that weakness on um
on g3 now and you've also stopped
herself from being able to play but you
take siege 5 those are you two on the
board I see why you don't like playing
IRA clearly clearly magma stone is
preparation right yeah
absolutely it was like a twist off of
them
the last game he obviously prepared both
of them right now
the problem with playing b3 is that that
after Bishop takes e to I my queen has
to keep contact with the rook anything
had to play so V 3 would be mistimed if
I Castle I just have to analyze the
potential consequence with something as
ridiculous as Queen Age 3 my king is
still a little drafty right and you're
thinking about playing B should take
stage 4 but it feels like I should just
have takes takes an a3 and most of those
lines right like me I shouldn't be
afraid of the P sacrifice okay Maurice
give us an update what what what the
engines have this looking at this
position the engines like white but only
after Bishop g4 f 3 V 4 F 3 and play
that position and just play it with
space and Castle queenside right which
we saw happen before in the game in game
12 but as you start feeling a little bit
of echoes from that game yeah it's not
as easy no right it's complex and you
know I say you know you're talking about
being happy I'm not happy trying to
solve these problems okay I'd rather
have a queen position until I control it
I don't know what's really going on but
they are saying though very good for
white from an objective standpoint
ceci we have the supercomputer on behind
my back that this is a great position
and it's all about that space I'm not
surprised Queen moves castles etc white
team's always like computers seem to
always like why even E's like specially
combines and particularly than the ones
with 95 as Matthew Stadler and Natasha
Reagan and pointed out in an article on
just 24 where they analyzed Bobby's
games with alpha 0 alpha zero loves base
95 line in against especially so it
seems like it's always saying whites
better right
that's know and it's a very risky for
black that's why it is a little puzzling
but this was Magnus's plan before the
match and he stuck with it and hey it's
good for the fans I always thought about
that alpha0 program and it's just such a
phenomenal number it played 44 million
games against itself Bishop g4 on the
board Bishop g4 on the board are you
looking at lines with the table h5 or
cage 5 Bishop g4 can attract that Queen
feather huh I definitely wasn't looking
for those lines they're not the menu now
anyway Bishop g4 on the board okay an f3
recommended by far right now okay f3 has
the computers stamp of approval f2 f3
you know it's funny I'm just reluctant
to play it Maurice on it your board is
incorrect there's a bishop one in three
know how you got to go back to c1 on
your board that high Bishop to e3 Oh
Bishop e3 Bishop e7 was played sorry so
we must have had Bishop e3 Bishop oops
that's been the case for Bishop e3
bishop I must have missed a move I'm
sorry Bishop e2 and Bishop g4 so now I'm
up to date with the players right so
okay so f3 right is is the recommended
move we've seen this type of position
like cat but f3 and Castle queenside as
a plan with that pawn already sitting on
a four there's got to be some memories
from Fabi of getting back in is mine
going wait a minute I've been there
before and now it's not the same attack
assault against my position right but
but but you gotta wonder is it something
that's that you want to do yeah because
once you point of three you're
committing yourself yeah to that arey
King side right I'm sure this is gonna
be a hard this is a very difficult
decision on his part despite the fact
that f3 is good according to the engines
this is saying that one of those human
moments you now you have recollection in
your brain game 12 yeah I was getting
made it
getting attacked I really want to put my
king over there is it better now the
circumstance is clearly better there's
no night f8d 75 on the board already
right you already
you're not dis harmonizing with your
work on h2 right you're not coming under
all that fire so it is possible to do
but will he do it very difficult you
Minh decision right now we got news on
the guy to Queenie to Queen a5 are on
the board yeah I was about to say I'm
thinking rook c1 I I mean I understand
you know f3 gaining attempt eluding the
bishop away but I just didn't like all
the weakness it was creating rooks e1 is
one of those tempos that's very useful
for white he knows that the rook is
going to be well placed on c1 no matter
what kind of middlegame position after
the trade bone on h5 stands out like a
sore thumb it's a real real weakness you
don't as black you want to castle but
you don't want to just cough up a pawn
for free and that was why magnus played
the move Queen f5 to prepare his
castling and protect the pawn on h5 now
with the rook on c1 I'm starting to
think should I go for it ending
remember when Gary was on our show
during game 12 he was saying the problem
with the position was White's came and
he was looking to play the move Queen b6
and trade off Queens so imagine we play
the move Queen c2 here guys I'm trying
to induce you to trade and then I'll
stick my King in the center and I'll
play for my Queen side breaks FLA Queen
f3
Queenie for ya all right you don't mind
me trading and playing at five maybe I
do maybe I don't
yeah it's hard to say
should I be doing this double-edged once
again I mean I've got ideas of taking
and efore and clicking and that I mean I
would not want to play this without a
lot of preparation I really want to be
reassured
this is sharp and I want to tell you as
a Sicilian player myself with black when
it's always getting funky and you can
just start dropping some moves moves
come a lot easier
I know right and and you don't worry
about when black starts making nice
dynamic moves you want to control black
before you punch him in the face you
know and start swinging because blacks
got got gloves to take the gloves off
and show some knuckles so you need to be
careful here and I think that I think
that Magnus doesn't feel right now
Magnus doesn't feel worse in this
position you've right well the problem
I'm having with white is I really want
to put my knight on e4 which brings me
back to playing the move f2 f3 unless
I'm willing to move my bishop like
something like you should be six sorry
back up the move c5 is on the board
maybe five sharpening in the a move that
really is triple edged I'm in my new
shaver man it's got like three actually
it's got close to five blades yeah
you're gonna be happy though because
because the rock and just Castle here
and ask you what your point is because
me what was what was the point of c5 if
we take on c5 I'm assuming yeah of
course I mean why why he's trying to do
there's any self-respecting poori there
something like that Bishop takes I'm
sorry I just Bishop takes on excellent
well it's not the issue you can still
castle here right but then there's e6 ah
this d6 yeah I'm getting that tempo that
could be upsetting these are fun times
for
for what that's what I meant I mean yeah
yeah it could be upsetting I I could see
why why black would not want to deal
with those this is the idea but castles
right away
castles right away is what maurices that
does look like a good move doesn't it
it's actually because it basically asks
the question are you going to waste more
time playing c6 or are you going to help
me by just trading on d6 the bishop will
be the bishop will be fine on d6 and you
want to play c6 got straight trade in d5
no looks very oh no you haven't give a
bailout maybe maybe yeah I thought I'd
Queenie for I thought I'd Queenie for
but you have 97 yeah there's it all over
maybe you're better after Knight takes
Knight stakes I'm hitting your C pawn
and your work but you're not my castle
okay so that you don't have to play d5
you don't even actually after c6 you
could even just say what are you doing I
mean you couldn't just say are you gonna
trade that doesn't make much sense but
your idea of take and take and maybe
something like I don't know
can't we just prepare this prepare d5
you mean yeah because you can't play 94
because of Queen d5 and 95 because of
Queen e4 and there's still 90 c7 track
but then at the end of the variation c6
is gonna be hanging yes so that's my
point if not that's bad yeah as bad as
what it is I've got Rhys what do you
have for us I do have that that's
something crazy on your board no it's
not crazy it's not crazy on a five it's
the same line it's just it's just the
same idea be c6 d c6 rook after c8 and
now you have to defend this pawn which
you know you don't want to do you like
you're sitting there going why did I do
this so that I have to start dealing
with and now the move worked a five
looking to challenge on the d5 square at
some point and after castles Queen b6
and this pawn is coming under heavy fire
guys really very fast he cannot hold it
up the engine saying that it is much
better for black right now this position
the center pawns are going to go down
the board while you're busy
writing the c-pawn black's gonna have
passed pawns as well example in this
position look at this pawn going down
the board and Magnus has indeed castled
I do have that now in the game Magnus
has castled and said this c5
demonstration too soon no real effect on
blacks position three inches now saying
bail out with CD six and played that
position and by the way be very careful
folks be very careful because suddenly
there's a tactical idea of Knight f4
that is starting to creep into the
position if you Castle or not you have
to worry about this move because I
capture pawn takes the e-file opens the
move f3 could land on the board if your
king is here there's mating ideas black
is happy the maximum c5 has completely
thrown away White's advantage now white
finds himself needing to equalize this
position quickly because black has
developed that's control of the board I
mean black is great you know it's either
greater it's premature exactly I mean
that's what it comes down to and what
the Reese is saying is that after takes
takes castles well first of all I'm the
big fan of this Bishop to begin with but
I wasn't realizing that Knight f4 could
drop on my head that's really bad look
at night eight or instead which you've
got covered
yeah and then I've got I'm dealing with
a dual threat of taking my Bishop f3 and
I could easily get made it after f3 in
Queen age 3 remember that Bishop on d6
is x-raying h2 so I'm ending up having
to play a move that I'm not happy about
Queen here quia age 3 anyway he's doing
for five you could take on f4 this looks
all true fabbi no piling on a hobby but
I check made I love to see those check
made from the door that I find so
disruptive again I thought that I was
gonna get the Knight to e4 and I thought
if I could do that there was adequate
counter play dare I fall back on my
stupid Queen trade idea its are begging
time to probably that's what I'm saying
yeah probably what does that mean do you
like that I know I don't like it at all
here we got a problem
and I have to grovel maybe twice at
least in this case I'm fighting to you
know Castle and put my knight on e4 and
I don't have to deal with Knight f4 that
Knight f4 is really well that's a thing
in the endgame the night on g6 will look
silly right
where's on the middle game it's coming
up with all sorts of beautiful ideas
that's why the trying to wrest the
control of the the light squares isn't
necessarily only graveling it's trying
to find the best move
well yeah but to defuse yeah the
attacking potential of black with Knight
f4 that trading off Queens but I don't
think Magnus will be so accommodating
his Queen back and I probably just like
queen g4 and you know for some position
like this where I don't know one day f5
and you always gotta walk it watch out
for those Knight f4 ideas you know I
really don't want to hear that line so
you can grovel
thanks ace Queen c2 yeah trade take on
c2
yes seems economy kind of happy route k5
rook a5 preventing night
five may be preparing B 5 and B for rook
c8 as well as pre-prepared 97 is coming
in in your pawn so you're still in
grovel mode but if you ever played b5 at
least I have to be 6 right
not really ideas to play 97 I think
Brookes first rooks case first I go here
here here in 97 yeah yes something like
this and I'm the one who ends up a pawn
down after rook takes rook takes rook
takes and yeah I get also unhappy and
also f5 was a move as well well here you
have Knight takes inverse D 7 yeah yeah
and and I will add that there was an f5
possibility there for black as well that
that could have popped in to play that
for on you and right now you know create
some other possibilities as a problem
exactly not in this position I in this
position but even here even here it
looks like there's potential for black
I'm out you know from getting game 12
echoes of game 12 once again remember we
were always worried about this ePHI v 4
in the night coming nicely tuned to e5
even at the cost by the way of an H
pawned it just happens that we're not
even a pawn down anymore I'm sorry to
say right now
Fabi is looking at this position the
morning he's been looking at it for a
long time c5 was a really bad move and I
think it represented a bad attitude
about the position and bad attitude yes
the wrong attitude is what I mean
because if you're thinking I have to win
this game and you think you have to play
like you have to win and that attitude
is a different attitude than if you just
say I got three games to go yes you're
up one you don't let me chill but he
might have had the memory of the last
game in his mind when he looked at the
position he said I gotta win now I gotta
take my chances I gotta play aggressive
moves if I see them go for them as
opposed to what you had the Oscar was
like
me squeeze you let me treat this like
it's the same attitude like a spiral pad
when he had to win the last game against
in Seville six on the board not an
aggressive move a defensive move
remember that attitude Kasparov said he
said play play moves whatever let's do
what it takes
don't just swing it the guy because you
feel like you have to win that's that's
the champions attitude Kasparov showed
that path just because you have to win
doesn't mean that you have to play sharp
doesn't mean that you have to
immediately make the game dynamic and
crazy put the pressure on the guy you
got white just keep playing and show how
strong you are right now a world of
trouble for Fabia's he's had to play c6
and see pond is not a target there's a
line where you came up with a really
nice move this move rook a5 that's it I
thank you for it that's an engine move
but that's a hidden but that move is
really strong to cover d5 and to set up
this queeny's possibility and if you
ever force trades then d65 and the c6
bond is artificially isolated you know
kind of ahead of supply lines so this
rook c8 okay that's a real challenge by
the way and by the way you don't even
need to play rock a5 it looks like I was
wondering why you couldn't play Queen e6
immediately try that takes takes root to
see a Queen c4 why not challenge
immediately with the move Queen to e6
I thought 95 was the reason right
because that was a 5
let's keep it going Oh Roque 5 now
momentito por favor sorry is this
completely clear so Knight d6 Queen
takes c4 rook takes e4 rook c7 you're
happy well we start with Knight b6
Knight b6 d5 yes start with that whoa
I'm a material creature of material
habits here rook b5 threatens Bishop b4
oh D
Jennifer I need I need a diva lifeboat
we have rook c8 and Queen c4 on the
board rook see we're here before slack
is ahead of tempo white wishes he was
castled so you could bring his rook into
the game right now white is playing down
a rook while all of black's pieces are
waiting to pounce this is an objectively
difficult situation for whites because
he's defending a sea pawn that he
thought he was using as a battering ram
which has now become a target
this is this just principally usually to
look at it from a principle standpoint
isn't black as everything like as the a
pawn down the board that he can always
use to push create more levers he's got
the past D pawn in the middle of the
board it might be pushing anytime soon
he's ahead in development White's King
is stuck in the middle of the board
white wishes he not only would be wish
she was castles he wishes that a rook
sitting on d1 already and even then he
might not be better well if you could
play 95 cleanly then he'd be happy that
would be a different argument guys but
like this down essentially to Tempe as
far as I'm concerned out of the oak this
is clearly black in the driver's seat
black has everything you'd want with the
position sorry Maurice question after we
have this position on the board after
Queen e6 what does the engine suggest
that Fabian we don't have that Bishop d8
boy that's that's nasty because he's got
two ideas he's got 97 which we always
know is a good idea to bring that night
on g6 into play and he's got ideas of
Bishop a5 to gain control over the d5
square how does the engine like this one
this is good for white it turns out
Knight d5 okay just just areum
centralized and check we're not worried
about because King e2 right gets in the
game
what about starting with Queen f3 Queen
a three
sacrifice on h4 castles and there's no
sacrifices your Queen City unless you're
gonna do like a bishop cycle I guess we
could start what is 97 we could start
with pawn to e4 and then try to fact
something for 95 yeah that's taking some
time though Jen just a second I can I
can maybe cover the third-ranked or do I
have time to cover this wouldn't I take
stage 4 just be a draw yeah that's my
phone cuz that's just a straight-up main
thread right which would force G takes
h1 then I have 95 all on the board
followed by the way that's 85 shifting
draw you want to talk draw white we'll
take the draw oh I won't mind and he
found the move Bishop d8 not the most
accurate move by Magnus and Fabiano now
on the defensive but finding good
defensive moves this is the nature of
rapid chess they don't have time to find
all the accurate accurate knockout
punches and Magnus's move this
positional inclined bishops at d8 trying
to swing his bishop into the game to get
his knight to e7 he probably thought
guys he probably thought he won't move
his Knight because I have this check I
got everything going and now he's going
to be looking and going wait wait wait
wait wait what a challenge because not
the C pawn is defended twice yeah the C
pawn this there's a rock behind it now
yeah so you want to win my queen now you
know I'm gonna play to two rooks for the
Queen then I'm okay so this is a big
shift this represents a fundamental
shift in the position that he's able to
execute 95 now he just wants a castle
and put a rope on d1 and White will be
smiling well here's the Queen there's so
many challenges I thought Queen e6 was a
much more serious challenge than Bishop
d8
I didn't see an adequate move but what
about 'if I've for after 95 I mean the
bishop idea of 97 that that that's an
easy one to understand but remember from
game 12 once again how oftentimes we
were afraid of this move Jennifer before
95 beside and the knight is ready to you
know jump once he gets to e5 it's
eyeballing some pretty 10
if I were to Castle you we just play
9500 you you told me that there was a
sacrifice on h4 I I've got at least a
perv for a purpose and at least maybe
more I'm not sure you can castle
actually very dangerous I probably want
to that lady five also so how about just
[ __ ] up to D for it it's prevent 95
make sense
Mabel says I'll have to take it if you
play 95 maybe we'll get this ooh this
looks super know your name but you pay
five right or we can i play Bishop 85
check now because can you two there's
clean up exactly that's a lot of things
frankly I'm afraid of Queen f3
in any case immediately because I don't
want to castle and walk into the
ramifications of a sacrifice on h4 think
I'm gonna have to play Bishop f4 I don't
want to deal with Queen f3 I really
don't want to deal with Queen f3 I'm
thinking if you give me a check yes I
can walk over to g2 army to f12 GT okay
this is nice is your night a problem on
8th on d5 don't tell me you're gonna
play rook a5 you're not a nice person
Bob I mean your knight is a problem I
want to actually take your Bishop and
work the part of this movie 5c right
exactly so I can't play work do you one
cuz there's work c5 you're supposed to
be helping me than that now you join I
don't know you're not feeling I'm not
feeling it what am I supposed to do
after Eve for I need help well I was
just I was I was aimed it should be
barely oh dear
Bishop before you're saying Queen f3 and
I say let's just Castle and see what
happens really well I mean I don't know
what else to do I know you can't and I'm
my thought was if you play Knight h4
it's a force draw but I mean with just
the bishop and the Queen and no way to
get your works and seems like that is
what it is all right so she's giving
Bishop c4 as the right move here Bishop
to d4 okay and then and then if Rick a
five-night to e3 and if Queen of three
castles let the pawn get captured and
just you can have the pawn rook H I I
find impossible to and yeah three
castles yeah and a bit of h4 and since
you say go ahead and play the position
[Laughter]
horrible this is not happiness I mean
giving black still only like 0.7 edge
even though okay I get R okay five but
but I'm really frightened of Queen f3
what was I supposed to do after are you
gonna start with your knight on h4 is
that your point
yeah I kept my castle work c3 is coming
ladies where's mr. draw get your first
check you get your second check okay
where's the wind you rooks are not
coming in the game so that's a bad that
was my concern the bishops not lining up
so all you got is a queen okay so I've
got ideas okay five okay this is
Jennifer's Rover rook up and oversee
three but you're not attacking deep I
have excuse me I have rook c3 I should
have mercy three oh my god no what's
going on Holbrooke g3
oh you're going after g7 and I was going
after you're my guy and you're lucky
seven sure and there's King f8 haha okay
but now I don't the trade Queens are you
comfortable Queen c3 here oh you have a
need for H excuse me I got you need for
is interrupting a lot okay so Mike so
how many points do you have you have one
extra night take C seven on the board
this one out good
and now 95 played by magnus carlsen yes
but his attack is blistering is
blistering right now Bishop takes c7
Knight take C seven minute immediate
ninety five drops on the board white is
at the moment up a piece but there's 93
on the board the the work on is not that
mad you got a knight now midnight and a
rook on C one hanging and the King about
to be ripped apart by sitting on the e1
square this is overact
this is crushing so what happens if we
play Queen b5 hitting that work on a
eight okay so first of all we've got a
hawk Osito so you play check okay so I
better I better move my King up King d2
to stop because Danny two would walk in
the queen of three right yeah okay and
now if you can't play Knight c1 because
the Queen is hanging correct so I stand
by my theory that this is pretty crazy
huh and pretty hard to calculate wait a
second just a second so if I go Queen
exactly okay that makes sense this it
must be what Fabi is furiously
calculating when he went in for this
lion we know he's one of the best
calculators in the world and Queen d5
looks locks right by the way okay so now
I've got to come up with a better one
like a free check actually doesn't look
like that's great right no root take CA
take c7
I've got Queen a a Intermezzo would
attack that's very important so rook
takes c7 you can't play rook take c7 cuz
I've got check and oops there goes your
queen but you could capture my rook and
that's actually winning for you that's
winning for ye-yes
so Queen d5 so Queen d5 and what is
Maggie having a mind here as it looks
like Nike three doesn't leak anything
Rick c7 actually you lose not an
show killer oh so just move the rock
well you are threatening check and check
hurt me you're threatening 93 check the
threat is roots Issa so I can't just
castle correct because then you're just
winning your piece back that was so if
castles rook takes e7 now last time you
had Queen takes a check and you were
winning this time I've got the
discovered and it in your Queen's not so
instead instead if I just play some
other move here because I Queen T'Pol
okay not a pawn but at least you're not
made it okay as far as get your came
after it be eight castle out of there
ooh sorry rook b8 yeah I apologize rook
b8 castles and then we're saying that
from work c7 just take upon on d6 don't
don't even fall for this yeah f3 check
Wow now what's the pawn cow it's hanging
so we can play Oh nobody wonders Queen
Queen takes be a check but then we have
works he ate right so that is that is
how that though well I didn't know if I
should take gen or play this I didn't
know because I know what you're saying
I I'm thinking I I want the four rooks
on the board because my king
I mean if I could just you know start
coming with Jack's rook takes you on
okay mean takes be a track see a check
to your queen right check to my queen
right on guard and then I'm just
wondering just just the threats of Queen
eight three and Knight f3 is it's just a
foreseen win where do you put your queen
you know exactly where should I put my
queen may be here so if you try to drop
in on me you can take money for the pen
don't I have my key for and then I have
to go
design Maurice give us an update what
does the supercomputer 85 played by
Fabiano Carolina with the idea that
after work takes you four there's 97
check doesn't look good
85 is a blunder I think we know queen of
three you hit the road every night but
then there's 97 check King moves but
what do you do if you just move the King
oh you mean like King h7 yeah oops what
there's a is there issues gender every
ever everything's been taken the problem
is CA is and it's been played it's been
played everything is wrong here this is
a fantastic game by Magnus just simply
amazing and he's rolling him right now
there's no nothing here for white white
is dead this activity by Magnus is
overwhelming yeah this is not good great
this sacrifice this was just a great
piece xe7 was just a terrible move see
something was not the right remember we
had that position yeah he had the play
Bishop d4 and stop the the knight from
getting to e5 but there was some ugly
there was somebody there but it wasn't
as bad it wasn't nearly as bad I didn't
want to play the opposite but I
definitely don't want to play this
position is a c7 hoping he was doing
something Magnus found fantastic
attacking move after fantastic attacking
move now you see why he is the number
one rapid player on the planet it was so
natural for him and that the equivalency
is just not even there this is a this is
a blowout match right now it is black
Magnus showing why he wanted to go to
this at all cost because he was so far
superior to Fabi in this form of play
one of the things that really stands out
not just about this tiebreaker bit about
Magnus overall is
his play is incredibly consistent he
plays really great classical chess at a
very high level but it's not like his
it's but the quality of his moves
diminishes appreciably and rapidly
that's really great high quality rapid
and his blitzes who doesn't matter the
format that much and the time control he
still plays consistently great obviously
I think that in this game twelve Magnus
when he took that role he must have
really had a much higher process of his
chances than the rapid an average well
some people were saying like three to
one he must have thought it was even
higher yeah I mean that's what he must
have yeah which is every way to justify
his I love his breathtaking honesty but
yeah if he's if he felt like look I will
destroy it I mean destroy anybody on
this planet in a rapid and blitz
tiebreaker they have no chance against
me then it makes sense well yeah
actually there was somebody who did the
math PokerStars actually bard Dahl I saw
him right then map and he was saying
that if Magnus thinks he's 85% chance to
win the tiebreak it could make sense to
offer a draw because there's always that
like a few percent chance of actually
yeah I'm actually the computer the
computers played that position
25:25 game match and it was twenty draws
four wins four black and one winner
white so it's not that actually kind of
aligns with that man Wow that but but
then you really have to think he's like
85 90 percent chance to win the tie
right then the draw makes sense but
insane
that now that you see those first two
games well Wow magnets just clear
absolutely sizzling first of all first
of all Maurice you know again jump in
Magnus play like a boss this game this
is the kind of position again it was
three results kind of crazy and unless
white like you know I was saying could
control the action you don't get happy
in this position and now it's like
you're crying for this position very
clear this is not the kind of position
where you want to give black counter
play in a knockout punch in game to
which it looks like has happened the
odds will be way stacked against Fabi to
somehow make this into any kind of match
but the the thing was that game one that
broke his heart that game one broke his
heart that rook and pawn ending that
should have been drawn well you don't
draw something you're supposed to been
you know you should have brought it and
he resigned the worst results possible
announced him he has resigned he really
an absolutely beautiful brilliant game
we remember that car yakking game that
Magnus sacrifices Queen from mate Queen
game before off the match this one is
that game for Magnus this game winning
in this kind of style in a rapid game is
simply just dazzling well I really like
I don't know I like the first game work
do you want in Brook e7 those moves
first game the first game up yeah I love
I just love Magnus's I love the couple
moves by back I think I think history is
not gonna go on your side when they take
the game from this match that's gonna be
the representative game of this match
it's not gonna be the first game it's
gonna be this well this one's more
spectacular for sure Maurice could I
take you it seems to me I mean with
perfect hindsight that fabiana's only
chance in this game was at that moment
when he could have played the move f2 f3
and if you don't mind please take us
remain a chance to get an advantage
correct that after Bishop g4 this is the
position it was better for white white
control the space but if you could just
show it was like variation that went
something like this your Queen c2
castles castles okay so it was back to
canceling long yeah it was it without
that this was a fine way for white to
play White had control of the space on
the board had no worries about any
breakthroughs like b5 wasn't going to
bother him because
933 on the radio not over here on f2 is
in game 12 and g4 straightforward and
then you get your thing as going as well
so it was just a chest position 2 plus
so f3 was the moment and then thereafter
after that just when he allowed Bishop
e2 he played a I mean we've all allowed
this Queen f5 just don't play c5 just
play on this side with our Knight be
five castles is a normal move right
castles is no problem he saw the King in
the middle of the board and forgot that
his King was in the middle of the board
and he decided at c5 was the right
moment this was a bad move this is throw
away he should have gone for castles
instead once this happened Magnus got
his chance of castles and then he was on
his back foot because his pawn wasn't
hanging now right he had to bail out
which he takes these six is necessary
and play that position out but instead
he played c6 and up the ante this was
really upping the ends because now you
better target on c6 and you still had
not castle as yet right and this was
disaster as soon as Magnus started
hitting and these guys missed up the 895
this e4 move also came with effect
Bishop d4 is the only chance to slow the
guy down but not c7 and Magnus just said
whack whack and boom in this 95 King 7
why didn't you try creepy 5
I mean Queen d5 was his only chance that
was original intention Noda I'm sure he
saw that he any sure maybe Ruby a ruby
it was the best was Bruckner was the
only move to keep an edge here by the
way root be eight castles rook takes
Queen taste in this position definitely
not a terrible dying now chance to
survive ok yes he could have done that
wasn't the first couple tries to just
like yeah rook takes rook takes as you
mentioned rook takes takes
room back to c8 this position White has
some things to solve White is definitely
by the way on the back on the back foot
defend this position but here it is two
points for the reigning world champion
Magnus Carlsen yes the draw will clinch
him the
tension of his title here at the World
Chess Championship that means that Bobby
has to win two games in a row to tie up
the match guys and then after that he
would have to win in the blitz but we
can't call it yeah yeah not yet guys
have to get on the board and next two
games I mean it's a Hail Mary
baguette you know but it's 5% let's put
it that way but there is still that
outside check it's all about well he's
got to win guys fabbi with the flat
pieces and that's the first order and we
will take a quick break as we see in
Spaziano if you make the most miraculous
comeback of all time and go on to split
the match with two straight victories
stay tuned we'll be right back
[Music]
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership Saint
Louis University celebrating its 200th
anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015
Slough partner with the st. Louis chest
clip to start a top-tier collegiate
chess team on the very first year of the
team's inception Slough obtained second
best University at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University you may have heard about st.
Louis's world-class museums art history
science even magic
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top don't
let all this family fun slide by you
[Music]
those kids it is st. Loup is always
exploring anybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to a world
championship edition where we are
watching
Fabiano Khurana fight for his life
against a magnus carlsen the reigning
world champion right now that every
favourite to retain that title and she
is up to a 2-0 start in the rapid match
and he only needs a draw in this game
he's playing with the white pieces
he started with E for knowing but it's
gonna be tough for Fabi to play a
Petroff meeting or windy up back in the
mat exactly so naturally probably played
the Sicilian but now here's Magnus
playing a line that would give Bobby
potentially left counterplay than
playing baroque see bind with c4 so
exactly the point is Magnus leading
Tuesday is open c5 hoping for a Petrov
which would lead to an easy draw for
Magnus and Magnus played c2 c4 on move
three an inch intriguing way of avoiding
certain things and getting into a Morosi
bind position where the pawns on c4 and
efore do we have further moves after
this Chen I mean a lot of a lot a lot of
games have gone Knight f6 Knight c3 and
so on we're up to date in D BRF today
you know Fabi obviously psychologically
in a really tough situation here yes but
how do you just focus on the board I'm
sure he prepared for this situation like
if I'm in a must-win right what am I
gonna do what I'm gonna call out the the
guards Bishop c5 okay that's pretty off
the beaten track I want to say Bishop c5
okay so obviously Knight f6 and pardon
me Knight f6 and gosh my auto is not one
allowed me to do it
mad f6 Knight c3 is the main line Bishop
c5 attacking this Knight I suppose
Bishop e3
v6 might be awkward for the first player
so dropping the knight back with a gain
of tempo against the bishop looks pretty
sound and safe the challenge that black
has is playing a position that has some
kind of durability continuity you can't
just draw right I know that and you
can't play a position that's just equal
that might lead to a kind of situation
where you're just playing for draw
exactly so so you gotta be able to make
it's gotta play some funky moves you
have to do something a little bit
strange at least that's what he's
thinking
sure against a guy like Magnus you can't
just play trash right you're gonna get
punished
so a really Herculean task ahead no
question about it
Rison especially with the black pieces
against very very well-prepared Magnus
Carlsen who has just been playing boss
chess in the first two games
phenomenally good but okay playing like
the most sharp line despite you know
potentially two drawls being three draws
being in the easier path to victory and
all you need is two and a half and he's
just a half a point away from clinching
his title is so how did for five years
2013 was when Magnus played right the
first world championship a year that we
had the first thing filled Cup that's
why I always remember it and Magnus food
play night to see to know you want to
classical tournament that he won before
he became the world chess champion ed
Zack and he was already of course a
number one player in the world in I
remember because he was here in st.
Louis and he signed the contract to play
in Chennai against Russia and on here in
st. Louis and he posed for the cameras
while signing the official agreement at
night c2 intriguing
I thought night b3 only because since
the knight was retreating
it seemed attractive to my eyes to
retreat with a gain of tempo against the
bishop
I suppose Magnus is thinking that he
would like to challenge bishops with
Bishop e3 and
we capture with the night on the III so
that when you got the Meraki bind with
the pawns on c4 and d5 so for example
we'll just put some moves on the board
like Knight f6 it's all about
controlling this d5 square if I make it
impossible for black to play d5 then
this pawn becomes backward a target on
the open half opened e-file so Knight f6
Knight c3 if we see castles this is very
often a key way of playing for white is
again just to keep black from this
freeing break d5 Maurice how the heck is
that beginning to mix things up here
there is a little tricky move here Queen
to b6 you put that on your board it'll
be 60 cold it's just a little tickle but
it's not really real the thing is you
can't move your Bishop over c1 because
of two's hanging I sorry baby
yeah I can't reach out to the garden
because b2 is hanging so you've got to
deal with that possibility and then
black will definitely snack on this Pont
exactly but black has to face this move
Queen to d2 Queen David - yes
controlling the F 2 squared after Knight
f6 1993 and now you can be very
aggressive with Knight g4 right again
because by the way I feel like I need to
be aggressive because Knight a 4 Wilfork
my queen and they should be yes this way
the problem however is the problem over
is you can also play very sharply
against you it turns out I move like
f3 oh and trying to induce you to come
into position with Knight f1 I mean I
have to in the night 84 and you got some
questions you do you win that rook in
the corner after your queen drops back
he's gonna take your Bishop you take the
rook and so let's say Queen c7 for
example Knight takes e5 that's a [ __ ]
you know he takes h1 and the move and
extend
and the pauna needs to is hanging so
you're gonna get back out but here white
seems like he has different moves queena
for is one move g3 is another to think
about it's just just different moves to
think you'd have to wonder about maybe
queena 4k meant by 95 or something but
that that's a sharp sharp way to play
you need to know it's okay when you walk
in there with black and it looks as
though
Fabi has played Knight of 6 instead just
going forward and straight forward
development with 9 f6 Knight c3 and
castles Bishop III played look that was
a point of 92 was to blunt the effect of
this Bishop on c5 when the dark squares
trade more pieces off if possible I'm
not sure if you want to play Bishop e7
now he's played b6 to get at least
something for the bishop get a pawn on
c5 and control the d4 square is the
purpose of this move so black will go
for dark square control in this position
I'm really proud of Fabiano in this game
because you know he's playing the
Sicilian this must be one of the hardest
things he's ever had to do as a chess
player to get whacked to zero in the
first two games come back it's black
like just emotionally I think the thing
about Bobby his he's a rock and yet I
just think every player whether you're a
fabien out your heart has to kind of go
out to him at this moment yeah like what
an ask you know extremely severe like
the Mount Everest please well on this
game I'm gonna be pretty darn impressed
cuz this is about the hardest like I
think Bobby's like one of the best
mental games in the world like this is
this is the the challenge the pinnacle
of the Mount Everest of mental game be
able to play well in this spot yeah and
especially when you're behind and it's
not just that it I mean Magnus has just
played two fantastic rapid chess games I
mean we might have a little quibble
little quibble about maybe one or two of
his moves but otherwise Magnus has just
been playing awesome and Garry Kasparov
did tweet about that he said that it's
absolutely incredible the difference
between Magnus's moves in his classical
and rapid games is so small that it's
just ridiculous it's almost like he's
playing just as well
the the margin of error is so small fire
less time on his call and that's funny
because Gary was so critical about the
drawl offer it seems like he's dialing
back again but that's the thing they're
two such different world champions and
this is Magnus going for his own you
know going after Gary for goat status
right I don't think he's doing in this
match but lifetime he's a guy who has a
chance absolutely I mean we number one
in the world he's been number one in the
world from seven eight years already
it's and and he's been world champion
since 2013 well also let's note yes I
think Nakamura have said it that the
best player in the world should be the
best at all time controls and there are
a lot of people who criticize this time
control who say we don't want to see
rapid chess we don't want to see blitz
classical chess should be decided by
classical means are you trying to decide
who the world's best player is the world
champion or are you just trying to
decide with a classical world champion
as many people say we want to decide
with the classical world champion is
because we do have work world rapid and
the world blitz so why not decide who
the world classical champion is well
this kind of format also shows that you
can decide all of it in one go he may
not be the dominant classical player
that he was in the past but overall he's
got all the skills if you're gonna go
into battle who do you pick any time
control you pick Magnus you want to go
into classical battle there's nobody
else you're gonna pick ahead of him you
might find as equal might say fabi's is
equal right now in classical chess but
that's all you're gonna get you're not
gonna say copies just better than him
that's ridiculous right now listen so
you may not you're still gonna pick him
if you're gonna go to the battle that
way okay let's do some rapid who are you
gonna pick huh you know where you're
gonna pick you're gonna pick Magnus
let's do some blitz who are you gonna
pick you're gonna pick Magnus
so overall he's showing that his overall
package of his game he may not be the
dominant force he was in classical but
overall this guy's the best player in
the world and he's showing it in this
competition he showed the time and time
again and in terms of the universal
rating system which incorporates all
three disciplines of classical rapid and
bullets how dominant is
Magnus I mean I think he's number one
but the question is is number two behind
him Jennifer well the universal reading
system as I recall it Nakamura is number
two by about sixty points sixty 28:59
for Maggie 2,800 even for Hikaru and Wow
and right next is MDL and by the way
five even just behind in that system as
well the universal rating system number
four yeah that's right
so obviously he's had great classical
results since the inception of the
system so that's a big reason for why
that is exactly but in this position yes
yeah we've just seen the moves well
let's escape I suppose this wasn't a
must-win situation for black guy I would
say black is pretty pretty satisfied
with the outcome of the opening what
would you say I would prefer white
because again I'm a big fan of the
classical Baroque see fine pawn Center I
don't mind playing the hedgehog position
is black with the bishop on e7 in other
words the space disadvantage but then I
don't want the piece set up with the
Bishop on c5 and the knight on c6
well yo that's for sure but also what
often happens is that in these positions
you end up playing rook c8 and 95 and
then this is this massive swap that's
almost like the board gets hoovered with
with pieces and pawns coming off you end
up capturing this pawn on e4 I capture a
Pawnee there on d6 and a massive draw or
you end up just getting suffer you
getting suffocated a little bit 95 okay
again fabbi is trying to cause some
trickery in the position he's willing to
meet the move F 2 F 4 with Knight g6
when the pawn on f4 is under threat as
is the pawn on e4 so he's hoping to
induce Magnus to play move like a form
madness doesn't have to do that
by the way he's got other moves that he
can just keep the position nice oh you
want this F for the Moto blunder
actually Auto blunder
yeah Wow look at Fort Knight takes e4 f4
Knight takes e4 I didn't consider that
right Knight takes Bishop takes Knight
takes Bishop take and your thought your
rating is night I did five and except
after you take it Bishop takes on c2 and
your queen is no longer defending the e3
Bishop five is meant by Queen takes e5
check to your king ooh followed by
Bishop takes rook so f4 is actually
wonderful word blunder in the position
blunder alert so he's not going to play
a four he has actually played Bishop
takes on c5 immediately yeah and pawn
takes was played Bishop okay to second
let me let me refresh my board F for
Bishop c5 b takes e5 okay attacking the
pawn on e4 and now if four is possible
if he wants it that looks like a good
actually looks pretty decent F for
chasing the night away problem for black
that d6 square as well so see how some
dark square weaknesses he's gonna have
to tend to well e4 e5 is another tempo
and queen okay so no g6 so that if queen
a queen d6 I can pick your f4 upon right
I definitely gotta do that yeah and I
was thinking I mean there probably I I
wouldn't have to play e5 right away Jen
probably I play something like Queen III
just maintaining this kind of I can get
keep fighting in this position right
well you're not supposed to be able to
do that right you know my queen is
protected by my knight on g6 right
correct but like I say this gonna be a
massive massive pieces
the problem with giving draws you guys
that like you might be starting to feel
okay okay I've equalizes black but
that's not that's not going to do the
track that's right that's why magnus
chose a solid opening like some Roxie
against the Sicilian that's like the
Sicilian is the most fighting opening in
chest but only if the guy wants to fight
and if he could shut but White has lots
of ways of shutting down the activity
including the Rasul emo by the way
that's a way of shutting down an open
Sicilian well he didn't allow it here
though because maybe you fix this Elia
that takes out the Russ and we mullet
leave but by the way we should note that
two years ago I guess now it's two and a
half years ago a little over when Bobby
had to play against kayaking in the last
round of the candidates it was on Moscow
that he played a Sicilian against Kraken
in a must-win situation sir yeah and
lost badly it's not that that's not good
a memory when you you're gonna play a
sharp position that's really not your
skill set because you have to win right
so now we have this position on the
board
we did see f4 and queenie 396 queenie
3d6 not work to d2 if you have this as
Magnus in any classical game you'd start
saying this is a Magnus type position
this is what do you want some little
weakness and you're gonna play against
you you're not thrilled with the black
pieces notice you didn't like g5 in that
position we'll go over we have it but we
have the position here and it's just
nothing to do for black blacks gonna
have to sit and sit and sit and the best
thing you can do actually sit awhile and
not do anything for a long time I think
yeah and I hope that Magnus tries to
make some kind of winning demonstration
that backfires because this is known to
be just okay for black not better this
is black as you mentioned gen you could
have played for d5 and maybe hope for
equality but that's what black would do
prove equality walk out and say yeah you
got nothing I mean not in a game where
he has to win that's the difficulty here
against especially we've all been
talking about Magnus's ruthless
pragmatism and that in the you know when
Gary came on the show a few rounds ago
he was saying that like in a way that's
a the
the risk aversion right and the
understanding of risk and their version
to it and they're trying to win and the
least risky way possible
Magnus if anyone is up to the task of
doing that it's Magnus right a lot of
times you say oh it's bad to try to play
for two results as white because then
you're gonna get yourself got right
right but it but that's that's like a
naive way of looking at it not against
the the Magnus who probably is really
good at at that kind of a parlay was
thought of Anatoly Karpov has having
this fantastic style of controlling the
action and and giving himself the the
choices and your options get limited and
reduced and stuff and this risk aversion
kind of chaste it's not the
swashbuckling appeal it's not heroic but
it's extraordinarily effective I mean
let's give the guy credit it's number
one player in the world and classic
Rapids and blitz four but do you had a
lot of haters after that game 12 which
which begs the question if he wins the
match in this round is he gonna do this
show the famous shush that did not work
against against Bobby everything you
look up well but I will say there are
there are a lot of people who saw what
he did and will still say okay you got
that but your clock's ticking that's not
gonna last forever and I think you're
gonna have young players who are right
behind him on the rating scale we could
mention a few names we're gonna think
okay we see how Magnus handled that
situation
he's already can almost conceding ground
in classical chess and that's we're
gonna try to get him they don't try to
get him here but they're gonna say mmm
we'll go for that but in the meantime he
will have won the war and so he'll be
very happy to keep his title over the
next two years proving that now meantime
in this position
Bobby has to play a waiting game you see
display the move eight-six the beauty of
blacks position is that it's not easy to
pierce and white doesn't have it just
straight forward plans
making a draw on the board so as long as
that remains the case well I can sit
there for a while
the truth is why can also sit for a
while black needs white to overplay his
hand right so black is black has no real
plans d5 was the only plan B 5 is the
best plan and only real plan to play for
it especially with the dark square
bishop soft there's some hedgehogs where
that Bishop could be on like c7 a queen
on v8 and some weird King h8 action some
some wild stuff but in this position
with the bishops off black is just
saying my d6 pawn is my only real
weakness you can't go through it
you just can't I'm gonna guard that with
everybody and if that's my only real
weakness that that's easy for you to
target then if you can't do anything
else
you can't triple on it you can't
quadruple on it you can't do whatever
then I'm gonna make a draw so Magnus is
gonna get to a state we're gonna say ok
my positions fine now let me see a king
h1 King g1 King edge 181 what are you
going to do mister and that's when
fabi's gonna be in a problem problem
because he's gonna have the perfect
defensive position but nowhere to go
with it right really tough really tough
must-win situation rook d7 Bishop a3
he did play g3 is expected yes yeah g3
just protecting the pawn on f4 rook d7
Bishop f3 the bishop the lights where
Bishop is being well it doesn't have a
great view the pawn on c4 blocks that
adds the pawn on e4 right now from
White's point of view the only piece
that really needs to be improved is this
knight on c2 working 8 Queen f2 rook e8
with the idea of d5 so that the rook on
e a so the queen drop back to f2 did it
yeah yeah now just like you said he's
looking to improve that 90 position by
sticking it on the e3 squared which
would be very very nice and very
favorable indeed again it's you know
it's funny I think after you played the
move Knight e3 followed by Queen g2 it's
very harmonious control over the d5
square yeah
I don't think you're getting in the
movie the break if the breakout moved
e65 is going to be well and truly
prevented when this night gets to III in
the Queen yes - G - then what about a
plan of yes of playing for this night
and I know it takes a while which this
night on g6 yes to go over to c6 and get
to and play for a 5 yourself and night D
for the idea being that you're trying to
make the bishop on f3 a bad piece
correct right if you just put a night on
that d4 square I know it's long-winded
actually a bucket makes the most sense
because there's just not too many active
plans in the position and from blacks
point of view these double rooks really
do tenderize this pawn so if you could
play knight c6 and like you said Maurice
'if I've and put the knight on d4 it's a
good way of frontally defending the pawn
on d6 I only my only concern is of
course giving up the d5 square + the f5
square as well because then I don't need
three is going to be well poised to meet
that but actually not only three that's
true and I don't need three has to deal
with my mind I go to deed 4 because the
knight removes itself from the control
of the d4 square precisely so I'm ready
to go there first and then I can still
play d5 anything that lands that I can
just chop off twice right I don't have
the superior knight on d4 right so
that's no 97 meso nonsense it's on the
board yeah absolutely on the board okay
so that's a slow but sure okay
positional tickle that kind of thing
doesn't know anything you want to have
in White's brain I am actually not
sitting here I have a plan I got a
counter-strike yes that's important
that's a little bit of hope you know if
you're gonna get hope you gotta do
whatever you can get that's a little bit
of hope the knight possibly going to the
d4 square is showing that black is
playing for something right one of the
big fears of playing these hedgehogs
style positions gen is that you're
giving up a lot of space and sometimes
white just takes the bull by
horns and says I'm going to go okay you
gotta give Bobby some kind of chance
exactly g4 h for g5 and I'm just gonna
steamroll you off the board now I'm not
saying that that now I'm fine
we got a game yeah is that what an Agnes
once I don't think that we're talk about
risk-averse
oh that's pardon me that's my that's not
an auto update that was just analysis of
the previous language we were looking at
okay because the point is if you don't
play for g4 and g5 and you know g4 h for
queen g3 black does have as Maurice is
pointing out a very clear idea of 9605
and dropping a knight on d4 and
potentially potentially earning an
imbalance that might be favorable if
black can get in all of those moves by
the way tigress played a couple of quiet
moves he played at age three age three
okay and after rook doubled on the D
line and they broke on e8 to d8 yeah
then Queen to F wait bishop - G - excuse
me - G - no nothing moves and the
glimmer of hope here is the increased by
the fact that Bobby does have a bit of
an edge in the clock few minutes what is
the time on the clocks we're at 13 to 17
minutes so nothing to write home about
but you can imagine that if that trend
continues there's a good sign it's a
good some tension you're right there's
still some tension nothing to the right
home about that's what some tension in
the situation and again right well let's
just get on you format for fabbi the
move knight c6 is he worried about e5
and the air takes knight c6 is actually
on the barrel on the board well I mean
it just completed and you know having
said a you know let's say B and let's
say C he is looking at the opportunity
to play e6e v followed by Knight d4 if
he gets in those two moves
he could create a dynamic position where
I like his his chance and I got to tell
you the engine thinks the best move
right now for white I think I'm gonna be
a few moves but the best one is g4 well
that well I was kind of pining for that
you know what I wish it was still on f3
but let's be clear it's a mindset g4 is
a mindset right g4 says I'm gonna play
for expansion they come get you yes
that's a mindset and and that's not the
kind of position we know Magnus wants to
play if he was gonna play g4 he wouldn't
played it was so this is there would be
a statement he knows he only has to make
a draw and then suddenly he's playing
moves like g4 and exposing himself which
he didn't do even in the game where he
was better with black right in game 12
we're not expecting him to do right now
to play such a move Watson if he doesn't
play that move the alternatives are
being given our rook c1 okay nice II won
bishop f1 Bishop back to f3 Bishop h1
King f1 king h1 king h2 none of those
moves inspire I mean none of those make
you go what is he gonna do all of them
are total groveling defense and here we
go you can and look g4 is on the board
with Queen a5 next and we have a little
bit of a brawl just broke out with this
move sweetie for that we won that's my
name prize chance
and by the way Tommy's only chance now
the engine is giving Knight a 4 as best
the point being to be able to drive the
night off of f6 and then breakthrough on
c5 and this game just went super sharp
super sharp he played the most
principled line did Magnus and is a lot
this is gonna be good for black it's
actually good for white according to the
engines right now so if what white can
deliver a true knockout punch a 3o smash
would just be unbelievable he's already
up to oh but this game has gotten sharp
in his 94 get played yet it has not
known yes employed but it's being given
as the best and it has been played and
Knight has been pointed now Magnus is in
his elements going after black
nine a four on the board and he's
looking to cut out the protection of the
rook on d7 with the move g5 so that you
could follow it up with Knight takes e5
and did this middle Queen eighty-five
precipitate a tactic that's going to
boomerang well he does have the move
Queen c7 he can just back up any should
bet he probably should be [ __ ] what
that's something that white will have to
be very careful about yeah yeah but it
looks like he has to and he thought a
movie wants to do but what alternative
does he have because all these
alternatives are are really terrible in
fact even even his best move is not that
great Queen c7 means worse so it's not
psychologically what he wants to do but
everything else is bad I mean this is
now white exposing blacks last couple of
moves and this Queen 85 move was not
great and now he's gonna have to rush
back to c7 explain explain why bishop c8
has been I I'm I'm trying I'm first of
all I'm defending d7 I really trying to
play a six five Knight d4 well I mean
can't even play with g5 anyway I mean
that's g5 you find it is giving away
that five square it takes takes Knight
got it back up we've got a back up I
guess yeah and now something like well
your night on h7 has to find a way to
get all the way back in the game
something like h4 and etc et-cetera well
I'm just trying to plan a knight on e5
for the time being and yeah I mean I
didn't like backing up I don't like
backing up with Bishop c8 yeah yeah
exactly both of them are moves that back
up but g5 is coming in all cases right
nice harmony here but with with white
with the queen and f2 and the knight on
84 and the Dumbledore off yeah I was a
little bit even more worried if that
Bishop it's eight on f3 sometimes you
play for g5 and the rook can come
to the g2 square but okay but it's
already bad let's get down to zip but
here's the deal please here's the deal
if Queen c7 is gonna be met by g5
okay yeah let's play that line up Queen
c7 g5 take take take take nine eight
seven yeah now your deal is you're gonna
put your night on f8 with the idea of
bringing it to g6 and maybe getting to
e5 with that night that's one now it
might be a dream come true another
reality is you're threatening to also
play e5 Knight d4 right exactly that's
another reality
so you're worse spatially but you did
induce right forward you know in a
generalized position that's like
everybody's still on the board except a
bishop pair of bishops and a couple of
pawns right everybody's still on the
board this is far from clear how this
proceed so Magnus is now launches pawns
forward in the most logical way the most
principled way if you're going to try to
play for a win and maybe you know it's a
good position but at least it's complex
this is full of fight and antibody could
blunder in a rapid game this is this is
the kind of thing you hope for where
again it's the same thing as that game
one where you were black and you were
worse right you're worse you're down a
pawn you're black you're down upon and a
rook and pawn ending but this is the
kind of thing you would like to have and
if it was a if it was a an over the
board game you draw with no problem this
is the same thing I believe why black
wants in a rapid game you need to win
you're going to accept a worse position
forget about that equal boring stuff
it's not gonna happen you're not gonna
get it get the worst position but hope
it's rich hope it's interesting hope
your guy looks around and feel some
doubt and play some indecisive moves and
you get a break in it something is like
oh my god the game turned this is what
you hope for because losing doesn't
matter anyways the same thing so you
need something you're gonna be worse but
you're not lost and you're not
struggling to find moves if you're not
struggling to find moves you take it and
I think this is what Fabi wants will
Magnus go for this will Fabi go for
first of all he has a with legitimately
play Queen c7 and he's going to have to
do one of those rope-a-dope
come get me George come hit me
I say George I mean George waters and
Muhammad Ali come punch I need you to
come hit me
I can't come get you I need you to come
get me in order for me to then have a
chance and that's the position fabi's in
and he did play Queen c7 on the board
now will Magnus play the committal g5
because you can't take that move back
when you play it g5 might be a good move
I I can't see him playing it right away
now by the way he does have an
alternative 9c3 is being given by the
injured as an alternative with the move
Queen a5 being given his best 94 Queen
c7 9 c3 repeating all the way do we have
that e5 on the board what a completely
different move looking for equality is
Magnus a totally different alternative
but this looks like the engines are
giving triple zeros you're trying to
trade off all the pieces that was what I
was afraid that a lot of these cases
when you do get a move like 'if I've a
lot of hoovering takes place right right
I we look this what's the first thing we
looked at when I said 85 takes 25 Knight
takes e5 right then you pointed out that
black has solved his problems but of
course solving the problems is not
enough in this situation right hoovering
is commencing right so the angle ad
comes on the stage and just you clean a
man as well yes after Bishop a he has
kept his Bishop on the board and now we
have a dynamic position we do have it
open to waiting to the rook straight
mm-hmm for looks came on and now you
said Bishop a8 did you yeah getting out
of the threat of Knight takes b7 don't
you okay this was a situation this
position still busy it's not triple
zeros after Bishop a it would have been
after ETA sf4 but Bishop eight is this
chance to try to keep pieces on and keep
it rich and it's not easy I mean
my white to just show why'd you shuttin
every every every down he's close and
he's even better according to the
engines but this is not an only slightly
better but this is not done this is not
just done if I play the devil's advocate
I apologize to err all concerned
grab upon your greedy man I'm a proud
card-carrying member all right how do I
get them in here is that this Bishop on
a8 you're right Yuri preserved it but
guess what you're still the knight on c6
is still in a pending those are three
connected passed pawns oh yeah I got to
tell you the engine says Queen B to hear
which which does not really breed that
much confidence as the move b4 is
playable also Knight c7 that you like
before okay that's that's fair enough
what are you gonna play for b5 and push
your baby yeah push your baby situation
yeah that's really good
well I mean sometimes the simple
questions need to be asked and answer to
okay sorry that's just my auto-update
breather just take off simplest solution
right right uh we do have for me after
Bishop a8 we do have takes right yes yes
and so this is how you're looking at
Queen takes e5 right now just yeah
asking the question where's your big
attack Queen takes e5 Knight takes a six
well it is going to be two and there's a
long line that goes there but it doesn't
look like it's promising for blacks at
all oh because you're threatening the
pond okay but yeah but that tells the
it's going takes on a tune okay no sorry
Queen check first check first check on
yeah just move the King to an exposed
situation yeah first have to see this I
can move my knight you know I can block
with a knight then you want to block you
this is weird okay so go ahead tell us
line but the line please - Queen takes
on a 2 a 2 B 5
yeah makes sense we take some c4 whoa
Queen takes on c4 yep and now and now B
takes c6 b it takes c6 we may say we
check akka Seto yeah King h7 and and and
Knight d4 Knight boy 4 I gotta tell you
this feels like White has no worries
here even though he might be a pawn down
white looks like he's doing well Maurice
yeah well he's guaranteed that poem that
you can never do anything about your
best bet is to just prepare and get the
heck out of here it's after Queen B 5
Queen takes or whatever movie you make
you're gonna start looking for there is
one hole like Queen B 5
okay maybe 5 queen a queen takes on B 4
okay and your one little hope is that he
plays c7 right now but he's not gonna
play it right no place no check and take
the pawn on c7 correct so that's not
gonna happen and you have no way of
really dealing with this e6 pawn so
you're gonna have to go for it right I
like it in a perpetual check well that's
quite a long-winded variation but it
also has the feel he's on the board but
Magnus is yet to snap on a 6 does he
have an another reasonable
[Music]
I mean night about that okay let's just
have a quick glance at that one okay so
obviously I'm hitting the Queen I'm not
sure I want to invite whites Queen in
maybe the same line is before Jen Queen
d2 you know at least right and now I
have a choice between 1956 or Knight b6
what feels I'm trying to keep the
imbalance right I mean again
circumstances force fabbi to go for a
win even though like Queen d7 here I'm
just trying to same stories you might
have lady 95 or something I got I got
I'm gonna pick up this guy you're gonna
have to hang around no and the more I
look at this the more I would prefer to
play Knight takes a six since I'm gonna
trade the fair yeah I'll take a pawn for
my efforts Maurice what does the engine
reckon the super computer that is to say
all good moves everything you do is fine
but 96 is actually the third best option
Knight d3 is also given as a strong move
here just a guard everything just 93
stopping b2 and any penetration how do
you win for a queen side majority of
three versus one and also the statement
how do you win I've ever ly 93 and
something like Queen III how do you win
how do you what do you do with luck so
93 if I go back to break the pin of the
bishop by defending the bishop you're
saying Queen III or Queen a for even
trying to offer a trade but something
like that like how do you what are your
moves is black then now make a statement
that you're gonna try to win this game
it's it's trying to sad because your
only chance is that a pawn right now is
on e6 you have nothing on the Queen side
you're gonna have to somehow make that
pawn into a hero right and it's gonna
require a lot of removal of bodies out
of your way in order to get that pond
anyway
and there's nothing else in your
position to write home about so he he
could take on a six and go for this
forcing ish line or you could just back
up and say okay now now I've returned
the favor
come beat me I dare you to beat me in
that position so easy he's under full
control his Magnus right now in this
position and his intuition is so good
that he'll suspect which one it is to do
to make sure he is not hit right so 93
Queen III just taking a stand in the
center just one way to do it and Knight
takes a six also but everything I mean
literally every move zero zeros zeros
all the way down Queen III is possible
right now as well is another which looks
sharp in my eyes but actually it looks
really decent too he played the sharpest
one though he did play Knight to d7 is
on the board
oh really yes okay Queen B two on the
board as well so we're there okay in
this most sharp off the options there'll
be a knight trade but at least Bobby can
say my eight point is still on the board
there's only one pass point over there
not too if you had taken on a six yeah
so he's actually not three pump
temporarily but Knight d7 is on the
board Queen B 2 is on the board okay
yeah the miners are gonna get sweeping
off the boards on how in some of these
lines right well not every one of them
you know what the problem is the problem
is where are you going to win you still
need your a pawn I don't see any other
place to win this game you're not gonna
improve your pieces in some dramatic way
you need to make that pawn on e6 into
the star that's your only chance there's
nothing else and it doesn't see it
doesn't seem likely that you're gonna
make this pawn go down the board unless
Magnus does something crazy this pawn is
not going anywhere can I just like
foresee issue with white two like I'm
really concerned like all three miners
off and it's just over even or even
perpetual so you really like the knight
f6 oh I'm not saying I like it I like
your effort I was taking and then
playing Queen d7 but this looks even
better
because you got Queen FA followed by
Knight f6 followed by Queen f7 check so
nice cut I'm saying if we're just taking
off all the pieces 97 Queen g7 Queen c2
Bishop takes c6 I mean yeah and there's
got to be like some perpetual x' in the
offing as well like you go easy for
white there that's not a good way to do
it are we sure you want this for no we
don't want to do this oh you just get
yeah be careful how you win that then
it's even isn't it oh it's not even
pause do I have Queenie eight at the end
but then you're taking on b3 well hold
on a second a second right ninety-seven
Queen d7
we're running Queens eh I can Queen eh
that's what yeah I think is on white so
J is then at the end of the day we're
gonna have this Bishop before chakra
cisely so you can the team will be on
age seven and the bishop comes to be
born it's it's it's over I didn't get
out with checks right so you probably
have to play like Queen c1 check first
and then that way when you take on c2
Bishop b4 will won't be legal right so
I'll have walked into a pin on the
second enou you take I don't think you
do like that because now Queenie four is
legal yeah good point yeah
so what you do is you leave the thing
alone cuz you can check later okay so
this is this is the current position how
do we figure Knight takes Queen takes
Queen takes C - okay at once right I'm
gonna go Queen check which way Queen
doesn't matter and Queen CH hack okay
Queenie a chip alright King a7 take it
and now I can check on c1 alright and
now all I'm playing for is the draw
right so okay so ally in this this kind
of way I can play a Queen d2 check I see
so you can play still for Knight d4
remember my knight and then hope you
know we're still playing at least and
where you are still right do is having
me play Knight takes first step in this
but my problem though I saw something
else was Queen King age two
might have been instead of - yeah King
age - in this position and now Queen a
for wicked ever my night now I can't
with my night yet because of the Queenie
forecheck yeah you have to do it this
way good now we are seeing Queen takes
you to Queen takes a eight on the board
yeah left the check-in so how does he
breathe this is on is what is what he
needs to do in a little bit fast this is
the current position yeah no we'd be on
this Queen c2 Queen see a check okay
actually was Queenie a check for
posterity okay Queenie a check King age
7 and then Queen takes a a yeah Queenie
a check King to h7 and Queen takes a a
now Queen to be one Jack play not Queen
c1 check the Queen to d1 anticipating
let's say King age 2 was played that's
what he did so now he's figured out a
way to guard everybody he's gonna play
Queen d6 check and then he's gonna move
his knight and his queen guards the pawn
and his Knights out and there's no trade
the Queen guards the pond the night is
safe right and there's no traitor and
that's what's happened but what does
that mean eh wine and then after 94 but
then I it was the h1 instead of King do
you wanna know okay fair enough
King h1 is fair enough I mean but now
I'm thinking that after Knight d4 played
I could place before you can't take the
pawn on b4 because I've got that Queenie
fortune hitting the king and the night
and well you play Queen e4 and now f5 is
possible right a little bit of action
alive this move pawn takes will be
answered by M by Knight taste yes
because the pawn takes with now Queen b5
but only that yes but but the knight
takes your threatening Knight g3 at some
point not now yeah but but you know when
the guy sleeps on it and but also
important and keep the past epon right
just remember that epon even though it's
not any
actor yet but enough and and this is on
the board f5 is on the board G takes at
five is on the board it's definitely
still fine I love this though buddy but
this is sharply great spirit in this
game doing whatever he can to keep
something juicy you knowing that his
chances for winning the World
Championship are slipping away but when
you're there at the board you got a try
it ain't much but it's a little bit of
Hollow I mean lock position is much
better than it was when you go back to
that situation when Magnus had the night
on a four and queen was on c7 and there
was a g5 I thought you know Magnus was
just shutting it down with GFI that it
could actually backfire in a tighter
match where you know you go for the draw
but now there's this famous principle
that the Queen and I work really well
together yeah because the Queen and I
can switch colors they can play on the
dark squares and they can play on the
light squares when you've got a queen
and Bishop you're playing on the same
colors as your Bishop the Queen and
Knight has generally been preferred it's
a little bit overrated right we talk
about hard to see the pawn on e6 being a
hero you could play Queen f6 or maybe
Queen okay well I'm playing Queen d5
Queen III was playing Queen e3 oh okay I
was going to play Queen d5 in order to
be a little advanced inducing you know
what happens when f4 yeah yeah I'm
thinking I might play move like a 5 to
just try to keep these pawns on the
light what's your plan ya know I don't
know 5 seem like I my plan might be to
play g5 in King's you said whatever you
do when you start pushing those pawns
gonna have her pet the one thing about
the other position with your Kings II
little bit more secure this will be the
midnight captures the knight guy you
know
so keeping the epon as a little bit of
potential but this this now you shrunk
the board a little bit and also any time
you play a four you're exposing yourself
on those light squares agreed so you
have to make a fine judge been here yeah
nineteen seven Annette ik okay thought
more control and energetic at the same
time I can't argue with that this one
just feels a little bit more loose okay
my buddy done d4 is not that great what
if I put my knight on e3
how about Knight c2 as a truck as a try
I'm just looking for an opportunity of
maybe playing queen d1 Shack and the
only thing I will say about this
position he put his I don't need six and
nightly sin allowed before here comes
that's why I was thinking that maybe
eight five would have been six about he
must have seen this move before coming
why did he play this move because I
don't see what the night plans to go
from e6 what if he was checked on d1 and
I'm not sure I don't know before you so
service of the board on the board I
don't understand what do you go I'm just
I'm just trying to comprehend this
Knight maneuver because okay you now the
knight is you always want to know what
the circuit the knight is on and right
now the knight has found a weird circuit
play a few moves with his knight please
show me where you're playing to go with
it because so he went night-night 96b
for and Magnus took the opportunity to
play the move b4 and say well I'm gonna
start pushing this is you didn't stop me
I don't understand the move 96 this
makes no sense to bring the Knight to e4
that would just step into the captured
by the baby now I just played Knight g5
where is this like no is only okay he's
thinking maybe you'll get an f1 f3 okay
now we know what his plan was is to try
to get this pawn to f3 but boy you're
just you just encouraging way to make a
lot of moves that they think once that
was not that was not control sure what
about eight or what happens on that I
think that's been the mystery horse you
mind there's a if because if f4 there's
a bishop before check followed by Queen
b3
very correct yeah shutting everything
down for charging ahead with c5 was
Magnus ignoring any of the any c5 is
definitely yeah my vote pushing baby
you know parn good passers must be queen
Essex and now the engines are giving big
edge for white huge edge those last few
moves after taking with a Paul and then
dropping the knight back putting it on a
strained circuit trying to figure out
some kind of plan Queen f6 now on the
board and c6 is Magnus ignoring
everything and allowing a knight he just
blitzed out knight c6 whatever his
knight was doing it's not playing pure
defense so a bunch of wasted moves by
black because the bishops gonna be a
star now we're gonna get the play Bishop
d5 okay four was Magnus's choice just
trying to get the connected path pause
and a four on the board and now engines
are giving completely winning position
for white those pawns all five plus
those last two moves Wow by drawing
order he had to win that position with
black no sorry he did not have to let
this happen though he was right there
and could have played Knight takes f5
and played or played yassir's move 85
those were moves to control the position
dropping his knight back so who knows
where and it looks like he's gonna go
down for the third game in a row here
saying about the knight and the Queen
looks pretty silly as it you have this
done yep are you holding the protected
path fine you've got a standing passer
on c6 and now Queen d6 is crush 96 and
yeah Queen b6 will end the Queen now
you're tied in knots 55 is Coppa pet
anywhere no don't bailing out this is me
Domon the Queen covers all the squares
guys this is a dominant Queen here well
Magnus Carlsen showing that you don't
play strong wrap it against him he will
own you and he is doing it here
showing why it is that he was willing to
take all the outrage of the world by
taking a draw in a position where he was
definitely better as black and saying
look my edge on this guy whatever
anybody wants to say it's so huge it's
not just him being that good but his
edge on Fabi was so big in rapid chess
and fabi's gonna have to shore up that
weakness and he's gonna make a run at
Magnus again he's gonna throw up his
weakness and wrap it in blitz because he
cannot afford to have this kind of major
disadvantage in his time control against
his opponent no way in the world he
beats him if he's going to be doing this
all day and this position is total bust
this will be the most decisive victory
in World Championship history in the
tiebreak by far a lot of people were
complaining that there were so many
draws in this match but it turns out
like we're gonna have three decisive
ones in the rapids which is pretty
stunning not what I would have expected
I would have expected one decisive game
and then maybe the other three draws
yeah I like the Gelfand a non match
which had featured only one decisive
games out of the four and a non one two
and a half one and a half and problem
was two to one Queen takes on the board
guys and we're expecting the potential
resignation here new what do you do is
Bobby no this is crushing this is
amazing a one track King this time
pressure must also be horrific to be in
you want to be moving this fast because
I don't think I don't think I don't I'm
not sure but I don't think he's on on
second thought well the more he's made
so far the last two holes feel like time
pressure moves as well but it won't
matter King h2 played and this is
horizonte's Corbin ninety-fourth been
played and he looks like that's the only
move so after c7 Queen c3 Queen c5 I
think you can resign with a clear
conscience in that particular case
c7 on the board and Magnus will not give
him a draw I'll tell you that Magnus is
not accepting draw offers I think you'll
be declined comfortably and just let me
win this game yeah I don't think oh this
is the maximum you could win you know I
don't think Bobby's offering to my draw
here Bobby's a classy gentleman you know
he knows you know what happened he got
crushed in the in the rapid there's no
reason to offer a draw but you know it's
funny you should say
you use the term weakness that Fabiana
has a weakness against magnets just that
somehow this guy Magnus is just okay yes
you're saying the weakness would be less
against like LaVon or MBL no yeah
exactly well comparatively speaking
number one in over ten so we're we're
this is a big difference it's too big a
difference to want to go into wrap
itches we've seen Fabi not perform at
the top in the grip on the grand chest
or guy we've seen that in wrapping the
Blitz time it's on me that means this is
not a mystery to Queen C 3 Queen see
finest this this week we've seen before
and and Magnus knows it Nakamura knew it
Kasparov knew it we knew it the
advantage is big but Fabi didn't do
anything wrong per se what is he
supposed to do decline the draw offer in
game 12 when he was worse we're not
criticizing him we're just stating facts
we're not we're not saying that the guys
anything wrong he played the sharpest
line in the last game the especially
cough Sicilian open Sicilian right look
we can't bat guessing now we can't I
guess him he was playing we're not back
we're not bad guessing at all what a
great match you show classical chess
he's fantastic
we're not criticizing we're just stating
the reality the reality is he's playing
against the best guy in the world and
you better be strong and wrap it too if
you're gonna challenge him that's it if
you can't beat them in in classical
chess you got to be strong and rapid and
if it was somebody like MVL somebody
like Kuryakin by the way Queen doesn't
do anything but if you go Queen f4 check
I think I can just now I'll just step
back to h1 but you can also play Queen
before if you really wanted to in the
very beginning and just make a queen
there multiple ways there multiple you
like that you
this is what I wanted to show but
apparently it's not even necessary but
it's good enough I mean that's a
professional after queen f4 check we're
running away I think it's a long run
virtual well Queen e5 check you'd start
with the eyes instead of oh oh for sure
much much much stronger apologies
okay so maybe the idea then but um Queen
c5 queen III on the board I'm sorry gen
after Queen c5 Queen III was was fabi's
reply okay I'm I'm replaying and
analysis sorry just a second I will be
with and queens is on the board
Queens on the board and well Magnus
ended his previous World Championship
with a queen Zack isn't that right
against third a queen it so it's add to
add to that synchronicity now he's
ending it with two queens on the board
so we have the hour and Queen to g4
after f4 so Queens f4 and what is your
board frozen yet no III Queen yes I
guess our position board is for Queen g4
played we know this is the opposition f4
check f4 now Queen g4 on the board and
that signals a resignation I would think
because there's no Queen Jean and there
it is it looks like he has resigned
Magnus Carlsen retains his World
Championship title and an absolutely
stunning performance in the rapid
crushing just every single game he won
the first game was the closest we're
both men played spectacularly but fadi
getting a tough game the second game is
sizzling Sicilian by Magnus Carlsen
every single Sicilian we've had in this
match the open Sicilian has been
breathtaking but that one
finally some blood was spilled and it
was fabi's unfortunately and finally in
this game I'm having to play for women
like he never seen that work in Sicilian
trying to win with black that's that's
just not the position he wants to be in
goes to Magnus Carlsen as he is still
the world champion he is the best player
in the world he did not show it in the
classical portion
he is definitely being chased by a
number of players in classical but
overall he's the best best buy test and
he had a number on three oh that will
never be beaten in this system you can't
do better than three Oh in a four game
match and that means he continues to be
the world chess champion a title that he
won in 2013 absolutely dominating
performance after what was truly a fight
in a full-blooded fight where he could
have also been broken but he didn't he
bent but he didn't break and there he
goes three Oh Magnus again the champ and
his fourth World Champion title that's
right
twice against Vichy once again Sergey in
2016 in Fabiano cammarata
in 2018 put on such a tremendous
performance you know that was just
stunning by Magnus in the rapid but I
got to stay still hashtag team Fabi I'm
pretty proud of the incredible
performance he put on here it was on the
edge of the seat for three weeks and
like you know it it was just really
unfortunate in that final game that Fabi
instead of getting something with white
like he had in game it was the opposite
in he was actually under all the
pressure exactly well it's really
strange in hindsight I mean as we sat
down two weeks ago and we're ready for
Game one of the World Chess Championship
we all said to ourselves look we think
that this match is going to be really
really really close one our biggest fear
is that they get to a tiebreaks where
you know we feel that Magnus has a
significant advantage we felt that that
was Magnus advantage and boy did he show
it today it was really an impressive
victory by Magnus
shoutout to Magnus Carlsen and his team
well done well done and like goes on for
all of us we will get another chance to
root on Team Bobby okay as we have a
grand chess for finals December 11 to 17
featuring the top four players by
Grantchester points and that means they
did the first round we're gonna see
actually Fabi battle against he corona
the more I wouldn't by any words to say
about the World Championship challenger
that said I had I'm not
superstitious yes but I noticed thatone
Hikaru makes a prediction in this match
he's almost always wrong
yeah so I was very excited to see you
that Matt Betty Carew said that Magnus
was gonna win easily but then a couple
nights ago he car was like you know
actually I gotta say Bobby's playing the
best chess of this match for saying that
but seriously Nakamura did changes too
and lots of respect for Fabi but you're
gonna get to play in London as we see
MBL and Levon Aronian
awesome semifinals and the two will be
and this $300,000 prizes every year I'm
still in shock calling that we're gonna
be here in studio calling that Maurice
is gonna be in London and Bobby I think
is just sticking around in London I
think he goes with wisdom charism genre
back to germany just to chill for the
week or so between the closing ceremony
today in london and start of the london
classic sorry mary's you were about
saying so
Bobby's journey begins yet again right
it's going to be very hard he's got a
two year climb to try to get back to
this situation it's not often that you
return after having lost the opportunity
have you lost a match we talked about
that Smith's love when he when he tied
Botvinnik
in their match that first match he came
back to defeat Botvinnik
he was the Challenger yet again to
defeat Botvinnik and that was an
opportunity for him
Anand it took him 12 years fortunately
was able to go back again and again at
Karpov and never be able to knock him
off the mountain Karpov lost his title
Kasparov and then as he tried to come
back after the guy never got to knock
him off the mountain so it will be a
tall order for for Bobby though he will
have Swiss flop as a model yes you can
tie a guy in a match and prove ya next
time I'm gonna get you he's got a long
two year March the other thing that we
should note is the rating difference is
still only three points it will be small
consolation but a little bit of a
consolation if he goes to London and
wins the very first game he's the number
one ranked player classical player in
the world it's not that point so that's
something he can look forward to
if he wins convincingly there shows his
stuff if he can get his strength back
after this disappointment then he could
actually put a little space between him
and Magnus
as Magnus takes a little bit of arrest
so he'll say well you know he got being
rapid and blitz he obviously is the best
in the world and that
but now the March starts again going
towards this this desire to become the
classical world champion of the world
champion because I think you want to be
the best at all disciplines I'll also
point out I have to say you know a
little bit of nudge to my the folks who
say don't go to the tiebreak know we
don't like seeing tiebreaks we don't
like seeing rapid you might decide if I
arm again and blitz and all that you
don't want to see that happen if Magnus
had simply tied this match and retained
the title there would've been a lot of
house his Magnus really the best you
know that's how he backed into the title
but by doing it like this nobody's
asking any questions the champion earned
his stripes he said I'm the champ I earn
it I know that the challenger has to
take my title and so if I tie I can be
happy no I don't want to tie this is how
I feel good about myself I dominated now
you haters you want to talk don't say
anything because I earned my way to this
title and kudos to him for doing that
because he has his advantages in certain
areas that's right he had a lot of
high-profile haters including I think
most of the elite grandmasters in the
world are like why did you take a drawl
there mvl garry kasparov Ltd's fury
Judit Polgar so if you were in that Club
yeah I really mean to say this in the
spirit of this it's been an amazing two
weeks
Jennifer Maurice it's terrific I really
really enjoyed working with you guys so
much you make it so much fun the whole
production team oh yes so fantastic
studio silverback it's been phenomenal
working with you guys as usual but I do
have a really exciting announcement I've
been really excited about this has been
in the works for a little while we have
women's version of the same field cop
coming up in February I'm gonna need
your kind of top female players in the
world a 10 player round robin $150,000
prize hun plus there's gonna be more
info at us chess champs calm I'm I don't
think we have an invitation list yet
because we were waiting till the end
the Women's World Championships to find
out sure and a lot of people were busy
at that time but one reason why I'm so
excited about making this announcement
right now yeah is because the World
Championship and the Women's World
Championship unfortunately kind of
coincided which made it hard for a lot
of the top journalists in the world to
see the women and that this is very
meaningful to me that the ladies are
gonna get their stage here in st. Louis
and the Karen's cup by the way the
reason it's called the Karen's cup is
that is dr. Jeanne Cinque fields maiden
name so shout out me who's a co-founder
of the st. Louis Chess Club amazing love
it looking forward to it
that's us great stuff to watch the women
who fight to the bitter end we know
we're gonna see some fighting chess out
of some of the big stars in world chess
and those women by the way another shout
out to Joo engine for her World
Championship titles so the reigning
champs it's hard to knock him off the
mountain as you engine maintain her
title as well and that's why we have so
few title holders in history because
once a title holder gets there they like
to stay around I'm the top dog until
otherwise stated and they stay for a
while so kudos to both magnificent
champions for keeping their title that's
right absolutely I mean pretty
incredible you win June and Magnus
Carlsen that's a big parlay the Women's
World Championship our team is really
incredible as always we've got Jen who's
always making us a little good markets
over in London along with Eric who
provided some of the photography we got
Eric Mosel over here including the
famous jazz Turkey oh yeah that was
pretty serious we always have a great
team here and we're gonna be back for
the grand chest we're in London the
final stage and Grantchester and three
hundred thousand in prizes in that event
and then we'll have a lot more info in
the Karin's Cup by that point as well
we'll probably have an invite list for
everyone so you can continue to get
excited about that brilliant and Maurice
before you go over to London you got
some final
yes let's let's roll back the tears yeah
I know
well tears for Fabi that he didn't pull
it off for us chess as it would have
really caused some kind of explosion
here in the u.s. still kudos to him for
such a terrific fight his preparation
was wonderful he gave it his all just
the first stage even tying Magnus was
what a lot of people didn't expect so he
showed himself to be Magnus as equal in
classical chess at least for now but
definitely congratulations to Magnus yet
again you can't say enough on the
champion delivers the goods and I'm
gonna miss you guys I'm gonna be over in
London you guys are gonna have a holiday
here happy Holidays to all of you indeed
and I'll see you in February though so
that's something to look forward to no
but I don't see you for months and
months until April but now more chess on
the circuit looking forward to seeing
you guys in February and yes also happy
to be with this team what a professional
squad makes us makes our life so much
easier and always on the cutting edge of
trying to present chess in a
professional way broadcasting in a way
that we can be proud of so thank you
guys very much right I mean John Bryan
Quique Tammy and today we had Alejandro
helping us along with Jonathan for
getting up so early and joining us on
set and of course at the st. Louis chess
club we have Rebecca helping us with the
events brave general manager and Tony
rich was actually in London as well
representing us and it shout out to the
Singh fields for beating field effect
which really you know Dave Viviano this
incredible opportunity the desire to
move back to the United States and
represent the Jewish Federation knowing
that chess is booming in America and I
think that boom is just gonna continue
let's hope so I mean fingers crossed I
mean for me I thought that it was
absolutely incredible that fabulous
Fabiana qualified first of all from
Berlin and made it to the Challenger
stage he beat the odds and there was
some serious odds stacked against him
now he's gonna have to
that very very same mountain he's gonna
face the same difficult odds he will be
an underdog no question about it to get
back to this world championship match
stage so we wish him much much success
and and there's plenty of other American
players who are out to get them back
yeah that's the other problem you can
talk about all the exciting things going
on and chess for the rest of the week
guys but I know it's been really intense
and so all the team favi fans out there
I'm sending you guys a big hug still
much love for Fabiano Khurana the first
American Challenger for the undisputed
title since Bobby Fischer but we got to
give the shout out to the king Magnus
Carlsen because the king stays the king
in the world championship this year and
the Queen stays the Queen
yes she does I'm signing off for
everyone at Spectrum Studios
Randy Sinquefield owns that company and
then also silverback productions you
guys it's been great to work with you
happy holidays and I'll see you in a
couple weeks
kind regards from the st. Louis chess
club and st. Louis chess club staff it
was great thank you for sharing your
time with us and we hope that you'll
join us for the final London chess
classic have a good thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]